The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by on it.com that's o,
n n.
I.
T.
Makers of Alpha brain new mood,
which Brian needs to keep them stable.
It keeps him alive.
Ladies.
Gentlemen,
if it wasn't for new mood off the deep end,
I would have no brain.
You would barely be alive,
man.
Uh,
what?
What are,
what are nootropics the fuck are you talking about Joe Rogan?
What does Alpha brain is way too complicated for me to explain in a podcast when
I'm this high on marijuana.
So let me be honest with you.
You can you go to [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.
N N.
It.
If you're interested in nootropics are in luck.
And what essentially are nutrients as an Alpha male pill?
Can I have one?
It's not that it doesn't do anything for your penis.
It might make you like,
no,
I'm excited about the 45 one public.
You know that really it's a there,
it helps the brain produce more neurotransmitters.
The idea is it's the essential nutrients that your brain needs to fire more
efficiently and it gives you like a little,
not a buzz.
It's not like a coffee buzz,
you know,
it's not like a stimulant buzz.
But I,
I take them before every show taken for every UFC.
I take them for anything where I really feel like I have to fire my brain and I
really feel like it works and it makes it,
there's a bunch of different clinical studies that are on a bunch of different
ingredients that are in each,
uh,
you know,
the Alpha brain like is one formula and there's um,
shroom tech is another formula is about a bunch of different things that do
different,
some for sports performance but cool.
But there's Alpha brain shit is,
it's all new tropics.
It's all different vitamins that have been shown to have a positive effect on
human neurochemistry.
And some of them they use for like people that have Alzheimer's patients and
some of them are kind of controversial.
Look,
I think if anybody's interested in any of this stuff,
you need to just Google it and sort of research it and don't,
don't just start taking any pills.
But I could take you tell you from my personal experience that I've been taking
nootropics for a long time.
I firmly believe in vitamins,
supplements,
eating healthy.
I think just just nootropics is not enough.
Certainly you need to,
the most important thing is get nutrients in your body that before anybody sells
you any pills or anything,
you should be eating really good food.
That's like the most important thing.
They don't even know if you get everything exactly from a vitamin that you could
get from the actual food with the vitamin in it.
And there's a lot of controversy on that.
I know that,
uh,
it's certainly better to supplement to ensure that you have a good supply of
nutrients that your body can use to repair itself.
And it makes me feel better.
It gives me more energy and I'm just a huge proponent of,
of health.
I think a,
it's a super overlooked thing.
It's too easy to overlook,
but you can get into it,
you can get into it and it can help your body and your,
when your body works better,
your brain works better.
It sounds like Sylvester Stallone Club sounds like Cobra
when your buddy lived [inaudible] but uh,
we also have a kettle bells
and
battle ropes in.
Now these are the,
the newest addition to on at.com.
And if you,
uh,
have ever seen kettlebell workouts before,
they're essentially like a bowling ball or cannon ball with a fucking handle on
it.
And you swing these things around and do all these crazy exercises with it and
it gives you awesome functional strength.
It's,
you learn to use your body in an athletic manner to move this heavy rock.
And it,
it,
it translates into physical activities in a way that I believe that like
straight bodybuilding type exercises don't really,
I mean,
you can do bodybuilding exercises,
still be an amazing athlete,
don't get me wrong,
but I don't necessarily think it's the best way to improve athletic performance
with like isolation type exercises.
I've always felt like it's you're way better off.
Um,
doing things that move your whole body like Olympic lifts or it battle ropes.
Something where your f about what battle ropes are.
These long,
heavy,
40 foot long giant fucking sailor ropes and you slam these things up and down.
It's an incredible workout.
You do it in sprints like you sprint for 30 seconds and then rest for 20 in a
sprint for 30 seconds.
It's fucking nuts and it gives you insane endurance and sync grip you like get
fucking nutty forearm strength and shit.
Tom Rhodes need to get involved in this.
I take one on the road with you on a fucking bowling bag.
That's it.
My new carry on luggage.
Anyway,
go to go to ana.com
if you're interested in any of the supplements,
one thing we can tell you if you order Alpha brain or any,
any of the new nootropics there is for the first 30 pills,
there's a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product.
You just say it doesn't work.
I don't like it.
It sucks.
Whatever.
We're so convinced that you're going to enjoy it.
They're going to want to buy more and we're so convinced that it's a,
it's a,
it's a solid product.
I,
the last thing I want to do is rip anybody off.
I think it's much more important that people don't feel ripped off before you
even think about making money.
It has to be an even exchange to me.
So we wanted to make this as easy as clean as possible.
First 30 pills,
a hundred percent money back guarantee,
and a,
you're going to like it.
You're gonna enjoy it.
It's,
it's fascinating stuff,
but Google it,
look into it.
There's another product called neuro,
one guy named Bill Bill Roman Ascii.
Put it up.
Very similar type of product and I recommend that as well.
It's excellent.
But if you want to buy a Alpha brain or shroom tech or any of those supplements,
use the code name Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off.
All right,
you dirty bitches.
Tom Rhodes is here.
Brian [inaudible]
don't man of mystery
experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Power Full Tom Rhodes,
ladies and gentleman,
John Man.
And I don't,
I don't work out too much.
You don't have a table that's just a sales pitch.
I'm just trying to get people to buy rocks.
I'm sending cannon balls through the mail son.
It's a sales pitch.
That's awesome.
But it does work.
I mean,
if you're,
if you're down with working out,
man,
those pills sound great.
That's my kind of work.
I'll get you some of that.
Wash it down.
Yeah,
it will help.
It would help a little bit
more,
Tom,
if we get you into some yoga classes.
I bet.
I was just,
I was hesitant to say that.
Uh,
I,
a few years ago I was really into Bikram Yoga,
so was a hot one and I just love it and I'm,
I'm,
I'm not even good at it,
but,
uh,
you know,
I was very svelte when I was doing it and uh,
I'll do it periodically now.
It's good to do when you're traveling,
but when I was living in Los Angeles,
I would go to this headquarters and there was this little gay Indian instructor
and I hated this guy.
He was constantly yelling at me,
Tom,
you're doing it wrong.
You're doing it wrong.
And I'm like,
just holding the position.
I'm like,
God,
where's this going on my ass?
You know.
And uh,
one time he,
uh,
he was cause most yoga instructors or cream puffs,
they don't yell at you.
This guy would yell at people and he didn't like somebody would lie down and
he'd go get up,
get up.
This is not silver lake.
Like apparently like they're real cream puffs in silver lake.
But um,
one time this guy was,
I'm in this la one,
the headquarters,
I guess the actors or whatever.
Some guys go in there and their underwear and there was a guy in and he hit
these Calvin Klein striped underwear and the,
and the,
and the LEDs.
And he's like,
yeah,
he was like a couple of people down from me and the little gay Indian and start
to goes,
I just want to say you men who wants to come in here with your underwear,
what is that?
You in the striped Kevin Kline's do you think we want to see that I'm gay and I
don't want to see that.
And that was really awesome.
Well that sounds awesome.
But the other part of them sounds like the opposite of what a yoga guy supposed
to be like,
you know,
this is not silver lake.
Yeah.
One time he comes over to me,
I was,
you know,
and he shows me how to do some position and then he goes,
what's your name?
And I go,
Tom and I go,
so does that mean I'm not sure?
Tom,
you're always yelling at,
apparently there was another guy in the class named Tom who like apparently
really sucked.
Oh.
So he was yelling at him and thought he was yelling at me for like three months.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And it turns out it was somebody else.
I was just,
you were just like,
keep your eyes just locked in the position.
Just holding that shit,
trying to do it perfect.
It's kind of,
Yoga is very humbling because if you,
even if you think you're a Badass,
he's like,
Whoa,
a fucking good bench press two 15 and even one of those guys,
it's fucking hard to just stand there.
It's hard to stand there and certain positions because this is like a lot of,
a lot of those like really deep poses where you like,
you can't believe how difficult
right to maintain.
Uh,
what I love about it is,
uh,
you know,
you see old people that look fantastic in these yoga classes.
Well it lets you use your body and uh,
like,
uh,
like a real flexible way.
Like your body gets opened up.
Like they're doing these crazy things that are constantly stretching the tissue
and pulling the tissue so everything has a
right,
everything has a purpose.
Like a,
you know,
a lot of people have back problems when they get older.
Just the fact that you're bending your spine like that and then like certain,
you know,
neck moves,
you're massaging your lymph nodes where people get cancer.
I say I reach for a cigarette.
Oh,
how dare you.
Yeah.
I think um,
people carry a lot of tension in their muscle tissue and you know,
if you just stretched,
even if you don't want to take a yoga class,
it sucks to just sit there and stretch.
But I'm telling you,
if you did it just a little bit every day,
you'd feel more relaxed.
It feels like you,
you alleviate some tension.
Like your body's just got this fucking spring thing going on where everything's
pulled in eight.
If you could just,
ah,
you'd literally physically makes you feel like you've alleviated some stress
just by pulling that muscle tissue apart.
And that's like we,
a lot of times we,
we,
you know,
there's a lot of people,
especially when you see people in traffic and road rage and freaking out for,
you know,
objective,
we nothing,
we're ready.
That's always it.
Like you'll be coming home from a yoga class and like,
you'll see you're driving and you're own mellow and there's people freaking out.
You're like,
oh,
it doesn't even make sense.
Yeah,
it's a,
well,
what is that?
Well,
it's because this guy's got all this shit stored up inside of them.
So anything is making them pop things,
making it pop.
It's just failure after failure after fucking life.
Shit's on them here and there and this fucking bitch.
How could she say that and fucking get out of my fucking lane.
You know,
you meet the guy,
he's already on nine before you even hit your blinker.
Yeah.
That's all the tanks.
You know,
you hit your pluck,
you fucking gone.
You can't stay in your lane.
Exactly.
No,
he's in La is filled with those people are just so quick to blow there.
There's a space.
I'm not even cutting you off.
Crazy bitch.
I don't think I'll ever be on the cover of Yoga magazine.
Uh,
and I uh,
I saw your,
you're,
you're on the cover of fight your magazine.
Uh,
yeah.
I love to.
I read that piece.
It was great.
Yeah.
As a,
they're really nice guy.
I'm just a comedian that likes different things.
That's it.
I,
I'm not a real bad ass.
I'm only a bad ass if you don't know how to fight it all.
If you don't have to fight at all,
fuck you up.
But if you're good,
you probably kicked my ass.
So it's not really a bad ass.
No.
You work for the UFC.
You're constantly around like the elite of the elite fighters.
The world you want to talk about like Alpha males,
Geezer and we'll just,
you know,
assassins like Anderson Silva when you're around Anderson Silva.
Okay.
And this the self as a very nice guy.
Very friendly guy.
Always happy.
Very nice people.
But make no mistake about it.
That motherfucker is a stone cold killer.
He's a killer.
He's the greatest fight of that's ever walked the face of the earth when you're
around.
I go,
that's some humbling shit man.
You know,
you just know that that guy could light you up and there's not much you can do
about it.
There's not much you can do about it.
I hope it ends quick.
I've always loved boxing and you know,
it's amazingly easy like lightweights and stuff.
He sees these little guys,
like if you,
you saw him on the street with like clothes on,
you'd probably think,
oh,
I can kick that guy's ass.
Yeah,
they're like the most vicious.
Oh,
you gotta like dry a favor.
Yeah,
you arrive favors not,
you know,
he's a short guy,
but he's a fucking man.
You know.
Any normal do 250 pound dude,
the fuck with your I favor,
he'll get a hold of your neck,
man.
I don't care if he fights at one 45 or one 35,
he gets a hold of your neck.
It's night night.
You know?
That's,
that's,
that's a crazy quality to have,
you know,
to be just like a,
a human bulldog.
I know a lot of those dudes.
I know.
It's a,
that's a various humbling,
very humbling thing.
It's,
it's fascinating too because you're watching the best that have ever been.
Really.
It's like you're getting a chance to,
when I'm,
when I show up at work and watch the UFC fights,
I'm getting a chance not just to watch like the best of today.
Unquestionably,
the best martial artists that have ever existed.
Like these are the best of the best ever.
This is like an epic,
like peak of activity where like the,
the,
the technique and the like the,
uh,
the ability and the overall game of these fighters,
it's so much better than it's ever been before.
It's like insane.
It's saying,
it's saying how much it's evolved and grown just in like the past 10 years.
Well,
it's amazing the effect it has on the United States.
Like you see bars that are just packed to the gills.
You can't get in when the UFC is on and people think it's some Rome shits the
phone,
it is totally wrong shit.
But you know what,
the people were very entertained in Rome.
You know,
they never complained about the entertainment.
the viaducts might've been leaky.
It's funny that it's the oldest Ligia little poke you in the ass,
but hey,
what his show,
you know,
look,
I will unapologetically if defend mixed martial arts to the end.
Cause I love it.
It's fun to watch.
And for me,
uh,
you know,
if,
if we are evolving,
it's not happening within my lifetime and I'm going to enjoy what I enjoy.
Sorry.
You know,
people like doing it,
they like doing it and people like watching it and that's all that matters to
me.
I know a lot of those people,
they're very nice people,
but they have a calling and they're calling is to see how many people they can
beat the fuck out of.
It's a crazy,
they're essentially playing a crazy game.
What does it mean throughout human history?
You know,
men fighting each other,
uh,
and showing who's the dominant fighter is timeless entertainment.
It's why it's so weird that it's the oldest sport really that's ever existed I
think.
I think,
uh,
a boxing was like one of the first Olympic sports.
Yeah.
But fighting in general,
combat sports,
the idea of trying to take on another person physically.
The all,
the only reason why,
I mean,
it is the oldest form of competition between males for sure.
And now it's the biggest and newest sport.
Now in the current generation that doesn't even make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense that it like didn't exist all along this time that it
was only in limited farms.
Like they like dribbled it out with boxing cause little kickboxing over here.
They never,
nobody ever put everything in.
Why don't you guys did Thai boxing?
I was in Thailand years ago.
Uh,
you know,
it's interesting that Thailand is,
was never colonized.
All those other,
you know,
Vietnam,
the French and all these different,
uh,
Asian countries been colonized,
but
Thailand never was.
And I always thought it was because of the colonial white dudes came over there
and saw Thai boxing.
Like,
fuck,
I don't want an Ni in the stomach.
Will they have a weird way about them?
Don't take the time they do the snake charmer dance at the beginning.
Do you ever been at Bangkok?
Man,
you go to the fights.
It's so great.
And it's,
they play that snake charmer music and they kind of,
they're up on one foot and they're moving like a snake,
like a Cobra.
It's a wild dance and a acknowledge each other before they start swinging.
It's,
well they not,
they don't just do that.
They also agree to start out slowly.
They start out slowly in the first round.
They don't attack like American fighters.
Like the bell rings,
they charge out.
It's a tradition amongst the tie fighters to start slowly so that the bets can
get in.
Oh Wow.
The first round knowledge nugget.
The first round I was like a lot of this whack because that's,
there's still there.
Just as they got around it got real lazy.
A bookkeeper in the window.
They don't really go for it.
Well you know there's a lot of bats like man he got it again,
it's not like it started and you know more bets.
Well I think the bat,
the line changes,
you know the bets are still coming in.
They want to make sure that all the bets are in.
So they,
they get,
I'm sure they get instructed to fight at a very methodic pace for the first
round.
The first round you don't open up too much in the second round of bets are in,
then it's time to go to war.
So most Thai fighters,
they would have a disadvantage when they would fight in like k one because they
weren't used to coming out of the gate guns blazing.
They were used to letting this first round be sort of a setting.
And if they're a drenched in blood,
they keep the fight going.
In Thailand,
Thailand.
You know,
there was a movie made I think about five years ago and it's a,
it's a true story.
This guy tie fighter.
Uh,
he used his winning prize money to have a sex Jess.
And it was a little at a time.
So like,
you know,
he's,
he's half a woman,
he's got the boobs on and he's still beating everybody's ass.
And apparently when he got his testicles removed though,
that's when it was night night when that guy,
that guy really beat my ass.
I'm kind of attracted to him.
Yeah.
I think he started losing once he became a full on woman once he got his nads
cut out at once.
Yeah.
So it's,
you know,
hey Joe,
a question about your fighters magazine cover.
I want it,
you look like Cgi here for some reason.
What's up?
Is this,
is this your head like photo shopped on somebody else's body or did you actually
pose with the microphone like that?
Because isn't that weird?
It looks like they just kind of pasted your head on somebody else's business.
You know,
it looks like some Lee Harvey Oswald.
No,
that's just the shadow.
That was a,
I was in the octagon.
Oh,
that's cool.
And they just put a camera right in front my face.
He said I was standing on my corner.
I like this.
It looks like I'm kind of mean muggin and he looks CDI for side.
There's a bunch of different ones.
I to the one bunch of me smiling,
but that's the one they picked.
They picked it like,
almost like the guy's smiling on the cover of lighters magazine.
Silly.
I like the pictures on the inside.
Is that your pad?
The House?
Yeah.
I have um,
for never invite me out.
Time rides.
Right.
I don't like swimming.
I don't like hot dogs.
You know how much I love hotdogs.
Oh yeah.
This is a picture of your gym inside that,
uh,
that great shot.
Yeah.
I got a gym that's like set up like a,
it's like a cage and a zebra mats.
That's a great show.
That's a,
wow.
So it's like this,
um,
it's like a full MMA gym.
That's an old stripper movies there,
isn't it?
I'm trying to get sexy right there.
You'd be a great stripper.
I just realized I'd be okay,
but I'm lazy like Magic Mike,
Charlie Hustle.
I wouldn't be,
I would be like,
do you want to answer whatever your Tomo and you kind of shattered that thing.
I always thought like guys with muscles weren't funny.
Like comedians like guys who were really like,
but you're like funny and you talk about life thought that too political things
and um,
you know,
we should never conceived notion.
I had about muscle guys top knocked it out of the park,
you know,
ma'am,
me and CT,
we saw about breaking boundaries.
Who's all about Sam?
Precedence was all about milestones.
You know what I'm saying?
Watermarks high watermark.
Me and CT,
we go where we go way back.
Love Care Top.
He's,
he's from Florida
and uh,
I saw him in Vegas like two weeks ago.
He's not as,
he's not as buff as he was.
He kind of,
he's like a really good shape is not that bulging like,
um,
he was,
he got a little crazy and then he brought it down.
Really good guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've heard that from whatever to whatever.
It makes people laugh,
you know,
is a good thing.
Uh,
I hate,
I hate snobby Comedians,
you know what I mean?
I do as well.
Motherfuckers got problems in this world and uh,
my father,
um,
who's passed now,
uh,
years ago,
I got tickets for us to see the rolling stones at the MGM in Vegas.
I don't,
it was like 10,
15 years ago and,
uh,
something screwed up with the tickets at will call.
And we're like,
I'm like,
oh my God,
you know,
and we came all the way to Vegas and with my dad we wouldn't sell carrot top.
And you know,
one of my,
uh,
my,
my dad is the reason I'm a comedian and he had comedy albums.
He took me to like,
Oh really?
First comedy show and you know,
now that my dad has passed,
that's one of my favorite memories is,
is thinking about sitting with him.
You know,
my dad's drinking is a little rusty nail cocktails and you know,
thinking about him laughing at carrot top shit.
That's awesome.
Right.
That's beautiful.
You know,
it was super buff.
Nowadays.
Is that Dave Chappelle?
Yeah,
I saw him other
day at the comedy store and it's just scary how strong that guy.
But he was doing MMA but I never heard like online,
like there's a gym or someone was training with Dave Chappelle.
I never heard of any of that.
But yeah.
Yeah,
I think that's awesome.
Dave was always like really skinny.
I guess he got tired of that shit.
I want to be able to fuck people up.
Why not?
Yeah.
The idea that you know you have to be fat or you have to be skinny or you have
to be muscular.
You have either think funny or you don't think funny if you either,
you know,
put invest time into it and treat it like it's an art for me.
You don't,
it doesn't matter if you have any muscles that's silly.
How many hours a day do you spend?
Like writing comedy,
you don't have 40 minutes to go out,
you know?
Right.
You know,
you don't have an hour here or there.
Right.
In that old model of like the,
the,
the alcoholic comedian,
it didn't take care of himself.
I mean of the 80s,
you know,
that,
uh,
I don't like those people have all died.
Yeah.
And they didn't look like they were having a good time at the end.
You know,
that that alcoholic life is a tough,
tough life,
you know,
dominant.
Where a good friend of mine,
uh,
recently quit.
I quit for like 17,
18 days.
He hasn't had a drink.
And you know,
he's just talking on the podcast yesterday we did the icehouse chronicles and he
was just talking about how great he feels and it's amazing to wake up and not
have a hangover.
He was planning for hangovers.
He would like schedule flights.
Like I don't want to get up there and I'll be over.
Like he knew he was going to feel like shit and he said it just the 16,
70 days,
he goes,
I feel sharp.
I took a break from drinking for the month of March.
And uh,
it was remarkable how sharp I was on stage and how clear minded,
you know,
without having a beer too.
Yeah.
Well the body is a fucking machine man.
And when you throw some shit in it that it has to deal with,
you know,
but you know,
you get older and you know your body changes.
You know what I mean?
You know,
everybody can remember when you're younger and you could just get plastered at a
party and then wake up the next day and help a friend move and then play
softball in the afternoon.
It was,
we have a theory about that and I think that when you're younger,
you're less aware of your body.
You're less aware of the consequences of being exhausted.
You less aware of what you've done when you,
you poison yourself and you fucking wake up hung over.
When you get older,
you know what you did.
And so when you get older you really accept it and think about it and dwell on
it.
Well,
I could barely leave the bad nowadays.
I never used to have that problem where you like get up and you're just like
holy shit,
I just need to go back to bed and call this day off because it's been,
I've never had that when I was 21 you know you've got to get in shape kid.
You have to.
I know,
I mean it sounds,
it sounds ridiculous.
Just need to not drink that hard.
It's getting in shape vape
as well.
You've got to have a body that's resilient.
You want,
you want your body to have the least some like day to day effort.
You want it to be fighting things off,
pushing things,
pulling things,
doing something where your body feels the need to be vital,
to have vitality and that that's like your body.
You have to think of your whole thing as one unit and if you look at it as one
unit,
if one part of it is like to attracting resources cause it's all fucking falling
apart and fucked up and shit and it's all kinked,
twisted and it's not used correctly,
it's never been stretched out.
That's going to give you problems.
It's going to cause you resources like you,
you're the,
your thoughts won't be as clear.
Your ideas won't be as concise because you're going to be dealing with this
fucked up body.
I always think like,
I meet brilliant people that have fucked up bodies and I'm like,
imagine how brilliant his mother fucker would be if he just took care of his
health as well.
Well,
right.
you know,
I'm,
I would never purchase such a thing.
Uh,
but a friend of mine,
his mother got divorced,
uh,
years ago and he had like,
he had some boxes of her shit and on the top of it was,
uh,
one of those Anthony Robbins courses.
I forget which one it was.
Um,
you know,
sees the whatever opportunity,
you know.
Um,
but it would be your own unit.
You know,
I,
I listened to these,
uh,
these like eight discs,
these cds.
It was the course,
and it's though his whole thing is you should start your day exercising.
Even if you're a fat fuck,
just get up and walk a half hour,
whatever.
You should always start your day exercising because when you exercise you like
kind of omit this energy and people want to do business with you because you
appear healthy and that you know,
even if it's just the absolute bare minimum,
and that was like his whole thing that he kept going back to throughout this a
business course weights,
you can force your bone and your day is,
your day is already a victory.
Yes,
you've already won because you worked out,
you didn't want to you to walk for a half hour.
Your Day is a victory and how much of life is momentum?
It's about getting your shit together for a little while.
We feel like things are going great and then it feels like things are going to
continue along those lines.
It's about getting the ball rolling right.
It's about,
it's about trying to just,
just a little bit of victory,
a little bit of moving forward and it feels like once things get going in that
direction,
you can kind of make them go in that direction.
Take control.
Bitches can take control of your own destiny.
Let's start a yoga class.
I'm not very good and I feel like watching visionquest the problem with yoga is
if you're married like I am,
there's too many hot bitches sticking their asses up in the warehouse.
Yoga pants on and that's just for Ronica is taking yoga training classes in San
Diego
talking about c p Penthouse pad.
It's not what you need.
That's not what you need.
Bending over in front of you in a Hob bonks in the hot box where everybody's
dripping,
everybody was all sweat.
It's like a
fucking better than Michael's video.
Better than running on a treadmill watching television.
Yeah it is.
But she said that there was like,
she skipped a class.
She like went and like I escaped one of the classes because they all started
talking about like spirits is she,
is she a ate a Brownie before she did it thinking I was just going to be yoga
training and so,
uh,
then she said that the woman sat there for an hour and talk about like spirits
and like all this other crazy,
I forget the kind of yoga it is or that the PR what we know Makenna okay.
He's said that he believed that yoga was a method for using cannabis,
that it was a,
a method for,
uh,
exploring cannabis and that it was to be co
it's supposed to coincide with the use of marijuana,
either smoking hash or eating hash,
and that that's what these crazy poses were all about.
It's all about achieving these like enlightened states of consciousness.
Why,
why under the extreme influence of edible cannabis?
Yeah.
She tripped out and said,
well,
if you ever done yoga side,
have you ever done yoga?
Hi.
No,
I haven't.
It's amazing,
but she might as well be astral traveling.
It's,
it'll be like a psychedelic experience.
Go to a hot yoga class,
get get super duper baked and go to a hot yoga class.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You'll have a fucking psychedelic experience or ideas to start teaching yoga
with her height,
penthouse friends.
Oh,
that's going to turn into a horror house.
Take one hour after they open before the first guy comes in with a stack of
cash.
Right.
And then it's on Yoga.
The Fuck Outta here.
And what do they do a little short term?
Crazy bitch
naked yoga.
Did they do that?
Well,
the these girls would do it.
Wow.
Naked Yoga class.
Jesus Christ.
It's going to be a fucking origin.
Yoga was going to pay for the kids.
You can go to India and do it like among temples and shit that I deal with
annoying people step over like dying children and I would totally be willing to
do that except I know too many fucking yoga people and too many yoga people
there.
They're trying to reverse what they used to be and they struggle and they don't
quite get it right and they claim to be all beads and roses and the,
but if you get involved in a business deal with those kinds,
they will try to fuck you.
Really young people I've had,
yeah,
I'm very recent situation stating that yoga people are unethical business that I
think that a lot of yoga people are legit.
A lot of young people are legit,
no question about it.
I've met some really fascinating people that were like addicted to yoga and how
it changed their personality and offered them a new perspective.
I think yoga is very psychedelic in that way.
But I also know a lot of creepy,
fake philosophical motherfuckers do yoga.
Well,
I mean you got to California factor too.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
there's a cute little cute little beak.
I'm yoga in Orlando that I go to,
it's,
and a,
it's run by lesbians who it's really cheerful and,
uh,
they used to be in a small place.
Now they're in a bigger place and I'm proud of them.
Well,
listen,
I love Yoga.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with yoga.
That is a little cultish though.
It gets a little cult like,
gets a little yoga,
like,
oh my family,
when I told them I was doing yoga,
they thought I had joined a call.
There's a lot of people that think that that's such an alien idea that,
oh my God,
they must be like living in a commune.
And when I say it's called like,
I'm choking.
Totally.
But the idea of,
you know,
this like aspired mindset,
this yoga mindset,
no,
my stay,
you know,
there's no,
you know what I mean?
There's like sort of like you're,
you're,
you've adopted this sort of yoga
thing.
There's this w and that's when I know you're struggling to get your shit
together,
Dude.
Okay.
And I love that this is what you're aspiring to,
but you're not totally there yet.
You're still kind of creepy.
You still kind of full of shit and there's a lot more of those guys.
There's a lot more of those like faith.
There was a dude,
he used to teach yoga class.
I used to go do this guy was from South Africa and really friendly like clean
guy,
open guy.
It was totally legit.
And he would say things that wouldn't even be remotely Corny,
say things that were,
you know,
just a,
a different,
unique way to look at your day.
Different unique ways to look at people that you came in contact with.
That guy was 100% legit.
Always very even in friendly and very,
very kind to people.
And the ready for this,
he operated his class on donations.
You didn't even have to pay.
You could go and take his class for free and it's in fucking Calabasas.
Okay.
This is a really super expensive place and these I would watch these rich
housewives go in and not even put money on.
Wow.
They would just go in because it was afraid they would just do it.
Oh I didn't have any cash.
I mean whatever,
you know,
I mean whatever the fuck their rationale was.
But you know a lot of people pay them cause it was,
it was so good.
It was so legit.
So there are guys like that.
But there was another dude that I,
that I knew that I was teaching yoga that was banging.
This guy's wife was taking classes there and he was just constantly like making
the moves on different
dude's wives had constantly late and they eventually kicked him out of the
community.
But I mean there's those guys,
here's those fake bead wear and assholes.
When Lotus Flower Tattoo,
I noticed you were looking for an afternoon hobby.
Yeah,
they were like,
like predators on dudes wives and shit.
Well it's funny,
it's like when you see a guy acting like a dick,
a in a Bob Marley tee shirt,
you're like,
you've missed something here,
sir.
All of it.
You've missed all of this.
Something about that,
about the program.
Well unfortunately man,
for these people that we see out there that are retarded in this world,
they were raised by retarded people.
I don't think they were raised by really compassionate,
interested parents who really put a lot of work into raising them and giving
them values and they were set loose like wild animals.
So it's like an aberration.
It's a fuckup.
It's a glitch,
you know?
And that you almost can't even make them responsible for it.
They're so stupid,
you know?
That's,
that's the big majority of the population were raised by idiocracy.
And you think we're heading to now?
I want her in the fields with the electrolytes.
I think there's always going to be a certain when when we ignore the social
aspects of like social planning and like the social aspects of like the fact
that you have to deal with all these poor people,
these poor people live amongst you.
And just cause we've managed to isolate them in the areas where it's not
expensive to live.
It doesn't,
I mean this is ridiculous that you would allow such disparity.
There's obviously something wrong with the system.
If there's people like that.
It is an education thing.
It is a discipline thing.
It is a like a tradition thing.
I mean if you have a tradition of in your world and you're surrounded by
failure,
it almost breeds failure.
And I think as a social engineering a plan,
they,
the government,
if they were going to do anything right would look at that and figure out before
we fuck with other countries we have to figure out this little thing right here.
We've got to figure out how to,
how to stop this cycle.
I Dunno the dumber you are,
the better you serve.
Capitalisms so you know there's a lot of low level jobs that need to be filled.
I think that's horse shit cause I think that's pussy capitalism.
I think that's like fake competition.
I think
it was all done with honor and it was all done under,
if,
forgive myself,
repeating myself cause I say this all the time,
but we should have like a real simple ethic,
you know,
don't be a fucking asshole,
don't be a cunt.
Really simple make money but don't be a cunt if you,
as long as you can get people to follow that.
That was Jesus as his whole message should be.
Don't be a dick.
That's all of Jesus's teachings condensed into one.
But yeah,
I don't know why the,
you know,
American government can't figure out that like,
better educated people who have,
you know,
health care would be better workers,
better inventors that we would be,
you know,
better competitors in the global market.
If I'm,
the problem is if we gave a hand up to some of these
poor people.
Yeah,
you're right.
The problem is everybody short term,
you know,
it's like everybody's thinking about themselves and profiting in the short term
and then the investors that got them in the office,
they want a profit quickly,
quickly,
quickly.
Nobody wants to like build up and spend a lot of money to build up parts of the
country.
That doesn't mean who's going to benefit poor people who don't even contribute
to the campaign or you don't.
We don't think of them as a resource.
You know,
it's just fascinating because,
you know,
we're trying to,
trying to find new places to drill into the ground to get oil.
But we,
we totally ignore the most important resource for changing the world that the
universe has ever seen.
The human brain,
we have millions of ignored,
potential geniuses,
potential world changers,
potential unique minds and million of them cast loose in the jungle of despair.
That is poor communities.
I mean,
if you want it to look at a resource,
there's no fucking greater resource than,
than people at the bottom of the,
of the food chain in,
in culture,
those,
that's the greatest resource ever.
Human beings like you have the,
if we wanted to make the world better,
it's,
it seems like you would have to fix the base.
You have to fix the bottom.
What's the broken part?
You gonna fix that Shit.
You know,
and people's a blue fuck.
Pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
You got to learn how to do that.
You know you can't just,
I know the baby in the woods.
I love the all the rich white people complaining about the occupy movement.
I was like,
why can't you just get a job and oh my God,
do the American dream.
It's always to anybody can do whatever they want.
Did you see Giuliani say that Giuliani to some speech reason?
You know?
How about you occupy a chop?
How about you go to open mic night?
You had,
you know he was fucking high five his when
they came up with that one.
Yeah,
they were fucking psyched.
He nailed it.
He hit the line and they're on their phones.
He hit the line.
It was brilliant.
Perfect timing.
The audience went nuts.
I just loved that white people were surprised that there's some unhappy people
in this country.
Ian Edwards has a fucking great bit about it and I don't want to paraphrase,
but about how more people,
everybody's been robbed by white dudes in suits.
Everybody like people are afraid of black people but white dudes in suits
including blah.
It's really fucking funny,
but so God damn true.
Like how could they be surprised that anybody would be mad that like where does
bail out?
What's going on?
Like trillions of what the fuck happened and where did it go?
What?
It doesn't even make any sense.
You look at the numbers that they talk about like you know at 13 trillion,
what are,
where is that coming from?
You're just making this up like this isn't even a real thing is passing around
some some new number like what the fuck are you doing?
Like where's this even coming from?
It doesn't even make sense.
$13 trillion.
What?
That doesn't even make sense to me.
I can't,
I can't wrap my head around more than than than $100,000 or something like that.
Anything more than a hundred thousand dollars I'm like,
what is going on out there?
I can't see that far.
It doesn't even make any sense.
It says it doesn't seem real.
13 trillion.
It's like stop it.
That's not even a real number.
That can't be a real,
we end.
Where did it go?
What the fuck is going on?
You did what with it?
It doesn't make any sense.
It seems like there's no way that she'd ever be able to happen.
The system should be what?
It should never be.
That money can just disappear.
Yeah.
She never be that like the fucking,
well sorry the shit.
It's not worth anything anymore.
It was all going to tumble down now and then
houses are going to stop appreciating and like what?
What can a wacky fucking system where we were running and we running a
confidence game,
right?
Well we believed in the value of things that weren't worth that.
That's where it gets really crazy.
When people were buying houses and then they were like,
there was like a little crappy,
you know,
drywall,
stucco places going for like five hundred thousand seven hundred thousand and
there were like 150
best,
especially in La man.
I've had friends that bought like in in La and you're like,
you're out of your mind man.
Like you're like in the belly of the beast.
You're going to get the shittiest price for your,
or you know,
for buying something,
like why would you want to live like that?
Stuffed in there like that.
Yeah.
La is the weirdest kind of city too,
because it's really spread out.
It never built up because the whole earthquake thing ever.
But it was like,
listen,
let's just fucking,
you know,
two stories is good.
If one of these things come tumbling down,
you see those,
um,
those high rises and they're like downtown La,
they just stand out like a giant.
I'll tell you what's weird about La is the downtown.
There's some really magnificent old buildings down there.
And like this one,
it had,
was a real,
uh,
vibrant,
actual downtown.
Yeah.
Uh,
pointing at that one point in time and
now it looks like Omega Man.
It's just like,
you know,
people don't bs and,
uh,
um,
you know,
homeless,
crazy,
crazy people.
People don't even realize how bad it is.
We,
we've talked about it so many times on this show.
You really almost have to go there to see it.
Right.
But I don't understand.
I mean,
especially all these great buildings,
why people don't just like move back downtown and no,
there is a movement.
There's,
yeah,
I know there's some lofts down there and lots of people moving downtown.
Well there's a lot of new shit that's opening up downtown.
There's a really cool night nightlife to like,
like there's a lot of good bars and a lot of good restaurants and it's,
I've been hanging out more downtown lately and it's really cool,
but it is still just too mixed up.
There's not,
there's not a good border of,
hey,
don't walk down this street because you'll die and this street's cool to walk
down.
I went the wrong direction out of,
there's a comedy club that I,
I did a spot at and I went the wrong direction back to my car and it was like
the scariest fucking street in the whole entire room and like halfway down the
street I'm like,
Oh,
this is the wrong street.
And then rent,
I turn around,
there's like all these people like behind me walk and I'm like,
Oh shit,
what the fuck is this?
It's straight out of boys.
In the or,
you gotta be ready to hit that a show at your son.
You gotta be ready to,
I slept no fly over your hood.
I stayed in a hotel down there a few weeks ago and there's a,
it was a real
cool punk rock bar on,
was this Linwood?
Something like that?
Hmm.
No,
I'm talking about,
no,
I don't know.
Punk rock bar,
something would,
we did a lot of fear factor shit down there in downtown La and
there's lots of space you can in a lot of old don't a water cannon on the
homeless.
People in the streets,
yards.
There's a lot of them.
The old buildings that they uh,
you know,
there's a lot of like,
like tie and zip lines through and stuff.
Well it's weird.
Like you,
you go to these old buildings in downtown La and you'll go to like the first two
floors,
it'll be like an American apparel factory and there'll be like working,
making jeans and shit and it's real weird.
And then you keep walking through there and then above that it's completely
abandoned.
Just dust all over concrete floors,
broken windows.
It's really bizarre.
It's like you'll have a 10 story building,
but you only have two stories that are occupied.
And then we would put up some fucking contraption on the roof and sling people
off the side of the shit.
I mean,
that was with,
uh,
the show.
We did that a lot in downtown la,
but
it's just weird factor is no longer on the air.
I feel really bad for the maggot industry or whoever was like cultivating all
the bugs and maggots for that show.
I really don't think that's much of a,
but industries collapse.
It was a guy just like breathing,
meeting,
waiting for our order,
really weren't going to get much out of us.
Yeah.
He bought a new car,
like house and he just show
the magazine industry
downtown La is also a where they shot Robert F.
Kennedy and I think they are,
no,
they shot him at the ambassador,
which is on Wilshire because that's not downtown.
Well,
it's kind,
it's Korea town because it was,
I,
uh,
I lived in the Gaylord across the street,
years ago.
I remember I hung out what she wants.
Oh,
that's right.
You can buy a house.
That's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We hung out in some really interesting,
uh,
circumstances throughout the years.
Yeah.
Well remember when,
um,
I had to miss a road show you are on news radio and it was like,
I,
you know,
it was like such a,
uh,
a juggernaut of,
and,
and had all this pressure on me.
I remember,
um,
they had the new show and now I'm seeing a comedy central show or what?
NBC.
Oh,
what?
Wait a minute.
Which would show you talking when I had a sitcom.
Oh,
Mr. Rhodes.
Dude.
That's when you are wrong hair,
right?
Yeah.
And have you had a comedy central show as well?
I did a lot of stuff for comedy central.
I did a Viva Vietnam and they let me fill them all kinds of stuff.
What?
I think you had a comedy central show as well.
Oh No.
You know what?
I'm confusing it with your Dutch show,
your Amsterdam show.
That was the show where it was.
It was,
you were the host of it,
but it was another name.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was the Kevin Masters show,
the Kevin Masters show or late night with Kevin Masters.
But there was no Kevin Masters.
No,
the Dutch people that bought that show,
uh,
the network,
they uh,
they had bought a concept,
they were going to do an American style late night talk show a lot of David
Letterman,
Johnny Carson.
Uh,
and we're gonna they named the guy before they found the guy and we're going to
call him Kevin Masters.
They thought that was like the flashiest American name,
a show Biz sounding name.
Kevin Masters.
And you know,
I begged him not to do it.
I said,
please,
I think,
you know,
I've uh,
I think Tom Rhodes is pretty catchy.
I really liked my name.
I've spent my life,
you know,
trying to establish my name and uh,
they go,
well,
you know,
um,
no wait,
that's the way it is.
It's going to be,
and you know,
it,
uh,
you know,
the first year,
every newspaper magazine interview that I did,
they would say,
who's Kevin Masters?
Why is it Kevin Masters?
And I would say,
I don't know,
they named the guy before they found the guy.
And then when guests would say,
Kevin,
I would say,
please,
my name is Tom.
And,
uh,
I never answered to it.
And so it was confusing for all the media.
And so they,
so the,
so the second,
uh,
the second season onward,
it was called Kevin Masters starring cameras.
So what,
what the fuck were they doing?
Is it just they were high?
The Amsterdam people?
No,
no,
no.
And that's the thing about Holland is they the,
you know,
um,
uh,
people,
normal people that don't smoke a lot of weed.
It's just,
it's,
yeah,
they say you're either a teenager or a tourist if you smoke weed and it's kind
of frowned upon a,
if you're in your thirties and forties and you're still smoking weed,
you're considered very immature.
Wow.
Well that makes sense that that's what happens when you allow people to do
whatever the fuck they want.
Well,
I,
me and my wife is from Holland and we've had this conversation a lot,
you know,
and,
and her perception is that in the United States it's like really cool to smoke
pot.
But in Holland,
you know,
they,
marijuana is,
it tolerated.
Um,
uh,
they educate the people that it's actually an uncool thing and that it will
deplete your creativity and your Polaris,
how the fuck did they push that deplete your creativity?
I mean,
that's,
that's what is this,
what's,
that's common cultural perception in the way they teach it to style.
They're very Calvinist Christian society.
They believe in partying after you've worked a 50 hour work week.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
you can do whatever you want as long as it doesn't harm other people.
And,
uh,
well that's nice.
You got a little clip of it there.
Yeah,
that's a,
she was the host of,
um,
what was Shazia?
Um,
God,
more ally shot really hot red headed woman.
She was the host of,
uh,
who wants to be a millionaire.
And how many years did you do this for?
I did it for two years.
Did three seasons,
uh,
on there for two and then the same network.
Let me be a presenter on a travel program.
So,
um,
and it's really an interesting story because,
you know,
first of all,
the thing about Holland is a that always amazed me is that the,
you know,
the drugs and prostitution are,
not legal but they're tolerated.
And uh,
but in Amsterdam they're like really strict.
You're not allowed to ride your bicycle on certain streets and the cops do not
fuck around.
You could be selling cocaine.
They don't care.
Do not ride your bicycle on the certain streets.
And then also like a,
you can get tickets for putting your garbage out a night early.
Those are though they've got a lot of really strict rules even though like drugs
and prostitution or are tolerated.
So I moved there for this Dutch girl.
I had started playing in Europe a lot,
London primarily.
And uh,
the comedy store in London is one of the greatest comedy clubs in the world.
And you know,
once you crack London,
there's all these other worldwide tours,
there's gigs in Asia and Australia.
And all over Europe,
uh,
once you get in with London.
So I had played in Holland.
I fell in love with this girl,
a little blonde Dutch girl.
And,
uh,
I ended up moving to Holland for this girl and we were together for two years
and I was doing,
um,
uh,
it wasn't much of a comedy scene in,
in,
in Holland at the time.
I was flying back and forth to London on weekends playing all over Europe and
everything.
So the relationship didn't work out.
And,
uh,
she broke up with me and I was just about to move back to the United States and
I'd completely fallen in love with Holland.
I thought it was just such a wonderful magic country and I loved everything
about it.
And these people saw me in a comedy club and they were looking for an American
to host the late night talk show.
And they gave me the job.
So I got to stay.
I thought I was,
you know,
this girl,
we broke up and I thought,
I'm going back to the states,
but then boom,
I get this television opportunity.
And,
uh,
you know,
I always dreamed of,
I always loved Carson and you know,
being the guy in the $3,000 suit coming out from behind the curtain,
standing on the x doing your little five minute monologue,
you know,
and so I got to live this dream.
And the girl that broke up with me,
uh,
for one year after,
she broke up with me,
she would still get together and fuck me all the time,
Holla,
Holla my kind of girl.
So,
uh,
I,
I was,
I was still in love with her.
Oh,
Tom and I wanted to get back together with her once in a few fine.
Was it Arthur?
You're writing poems?
Did you write a poem?
No,
no,
no.
But I mean,
she was an amazing human being.
And then I,
uh,
we're having dinner at this Greek restaurant one night,
and I told her,
you know,
I still love you and I want to get back together with you and,
and I,
I know we can make this work,
baby.
And she goes,
oh my God,
I thought you knew this was just physical.
I don't want to get back together with you.
So I got all upset like a 14 year old boy and I stormed out of this restaurant
and I jumped on my bicycle and I'm just peddling my ass off.
I'm all upset and um,
I'm just crying and I'm pedaling and I turned up lights,
a strat,
one of the streets,
you're not allowed to ride your bicycle on.
And my front wheel went into the tram track and I went over the handlebars and I
landed on my face on the street,
my forehead and my nose.
My Chin were scraped to hell.
And uh,
the next day I woke up and my face is mangled and I had to be on television
later that afternoon,
not a studio piece.
It was a man on the street filming thing.
And my face is mangled.
I didn't know what to do.
So I went to the buyer court,
it's the biggest department store in Amsterdam.
And I went to the makeup area and there was one chair open and I sat down and it
was this gay guy and I told them my whole life story.
Like I'm a stand up comedian from the United States and then moved here for this
girl and it didn't work out and she still fuck me all the time.
I want to get back together with you.
And she said,
I thought you knew that was just physical.
And I go,
I go and I got,
I got,
I got to be on television in three hours,
please help me.
And the guy goes,
don't worry.
I am a professional makeup artist and when I'm done with you and nobody will
know anything happened to you and I am also in love with a bastard and he went
to work on me and this guy did such an amazing job.
If you known what you were looking for,
maybe you could have spotted it,
you know on the television.
But I swear to God this man did such a wonderful job covering up these,
these,
these cuts on my face that I think the man saved my job and I went back the next
day with flowers to thank him and he wasn't there.
We went back the next day with flowers and he wasn't there.
I went back every day that week of flowers.
I still go back periodically and I've never seen the man ever again.
It was an angel.
He never,
I think he was an angel.
I think it was an angel was a gain.
Joel
or he died of aids that night.
No,
you didn't man.
He was,
he died of aids that night.
That's ruthless from makeup.
It's saw sour.
My cute little heartbroken story.
I saw a crazy,
crazy interview with someone from,
uh,
Colorado where they were talking about the shooting.
About how the guy's gun jammed.
Yeah.
And they believe that it was God that stepped in and jammed his gun.
It's always God,
he's,
God does everything.
Yeah.
I wish we had got there sooner.
Right,
right.
With God.
You can be available.
Oh,
Joe.
Like a lightning bolt.
You get settled in there.
Why couldn't the guy got a flat tire on the way over.
He got,
the only time God was there was when the gun jammed.
Like wow.
Suit.
What a horrible fucking tragedy man.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's so,
it's so terrifying.
My cousin lives a few blocks from here,
but bull of doing something like we're doing in these people,
you know,
they,
they do it for fame and it should be illegal in,
in our media,
in the United States to say the person's name in the news when,
when somebody does one of these horrific shootings on innocent citizens,
they should only refer to that person as that human Turd,
that human Turd,
the chop,
those people in Colorado,
that human turd that shot those people in Fort Hood,
Arizona,
Virginia Tech.
Yeah,
that would be a wise thing to them.
But no human turd number one,
target number 17 it's like a union buster sort of a thing.
People.
No one's going to agree to not find his name.
You know,
we've got to say right here,
come to go fuck yourself.com right.
And said he was the joker.
You know?
And if the guy really was that big of a fan,
why didn't he watch the first showing and shoot everybody up at the second
viewing?
Doesn't matter.
It's the whole thing.
You said broken human beings.
We just have to figure out how to fuck a human being become so broken.
What is it?
Is it,
is it a chemical imbalance?
Is he on medication as he psychotic?
I grew up in San Diego.
It's perfect.
There scares me though,
is that his mother knew that it was him.
When he came to visit her,
she knew that it was her son.
Oh really?
She was,
you know,
when she had heard about it,
she knew it was him.
There's a comedian that uh,
alright.
Caleb.
Melody.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He uh,
I think,
uh,
if I remember correctly,
he actually did a set that night at,
uh,
at the comedy works and then went to go see that movie later that night.
And I guess he got shot in the face and he got shot in the eye.
He lost his eye.
Yeah.
And then he just had a baby,
uh,
like a week ago.
His wife out of or girlfriend and abandon.
You can go to,
I think it's scalability.com support,
donate money,
caleb.com and you can,
yeah,
you can donate,
read the store support caleb.com.
Yeah.
So,
but uh,
that sucks.
That's,
yeah,
that's close to home.
You know,
comedian getting shot that's said any human to me it's just what the fuck it's,
you wonder when we're ever going to get past this shit.
When Trayvon Martin thing
happened,
you know,
uh,
and so much hate and anger in the media on both sides,
you know,
so many people claiming that the media was a,
in their portrayal and so many black people claiming that you know,
that this,
this guy's are criminal.
And this guy said,
the white people were saying,
oh,
did you see what his Twitter name was?
It was something and word.
Well,
and uh,
like,
like that justified that he got shot.
Yeah.
Yes.
No doubt.
It was not handled correctly.
You know,
there's a reason why that guy wasn't allowed to be a cop.
They didn't want them to be a cop.
You know,
it wasn't,
it's not,
I mean,
I know a lot of cops got gotta do to my cousin's a cop.
Yeah,
you can become a cop,
but you know,
this guy couldn't,
why couldn't they?
Well,
it's probably because there was some something wrong.
It's probably something wrong there.
Whether the cops are like,
man,
not nude dude.
Right.
I mean,
[inaudible] got a gun anyway.
Well man,
you know what I mean?
I guess you would want a real train security guard with a gun if you wanted to
have a former military or former cop who was a security guard,
but somebody who's trained,
someone who's like legit knows what the fuck they're doing and it's followed
protocol.
Great.
Well,
you know,
I'll show I'm from Oviedo Florida,
which is the next town over Sanford.
Uh,
you know,
it's on like Jess up this massive lake that's connected to the Saint John's
river that goes to the Atlantic.
It was supposed to be a,
it was a big port in the civil war and there's,
you know,
there's some ancient,
uh,
civil war era,
mentality still in that area.
You really,
really,
I mean,
you got,
you got like very poor black neighborhoods.
Um,
and in places in Florida and the south,
you know where they are on one side of town.
Yeah.
There's railroad tracks to the center of the town.
Exactly like it would have on one side.
White people live on the other.
That's what I'm talking about.
Like old,
you know,
uh,
American,
south separatism and,
and uh,
lack of upward mobility.
Yeah,
it's exactly what we were talking about earlier then if you wanted to fix
something,
man,
that would be the one thing that you would want to fix.
And I think rich people would want to put a lot of money into that too.
Like don't you want things to be safer and nicer?
Wouldn't you want it if more people were,
were friendly and kind and not like in desperate need,
you know,
don't,
don't you think it'd be better if more people were in desperate need for
whatever reason.
We have a hard time engineering that we have a hard,
a hard time looking at that as a number one priority.
Instead it's,
you know,
where the fuck are we gonna pull oil from knacks and w how much does corn get
subsidized this year?
And you know,
what does,
what are our gas prices?
And you know,
that's,
we don't worry about fucking poor neighborhoods porn that poor neighborhoods are
crazy.
The idea that you could live and know that in this one area is like infested
with criminals and people who are uneducated and people who are struggling and
all the crime rates are far higher and nobody,
nobody,
nobody concentrates on that.
Nobody fixes that.
To me using,
it's really,
it's quite amazing.
It just shows you how sort of self centered,
the whole idea of running a government really is.
I'll tell you how fucked up.
Um,
I mean,
I'll tell you how lame our government is.
Um,
I was driving with my wife,
uh,
last year and am I where I was just talking,
you know,
about Guantanamo Bay and these people getting tortured and everything and I was
like,
mmm,
I wonder what the top 10 songs were that we tortured people with at Guantanamo
Bay.
And so she gets on the iPhone and she looked it up and you're not going to be
the number one song that we torture people with and go on Tottenham,
obey a it by Ben called a seed or diet aside.
It's called fuck your God.
It's like a very loud,
uh,
death metal song.
Okay.
So that,
that,
that sounds appropriate for torturing people.
But like a number two was like,
uh,
no,
it was like,
it was like a,
I was like American Pie by Don Mclean.
Oh Wow.
Which is not a bad number.
And then,
uh,
I think number three was,
we will rock you.
We are the champions by queen the torture music.
I listen to that Brian May guitar riff forever.
I think what they're probably doing,
it's just repetitively breaking them down with noise.
Well,
we can't even get our torture songs.
Right.
Wouldn't it be great to know to make that playlist,
that platelet [inaudible] I would not have that if I was going to make that
playlist.
It would be like Helen Reddy,
I am woman a hundred times in a row.
I would talk.
I talk just,
Oh,
some of it.
Lots of Womans in Pakistan.
Me,
it's a big compound.
There's very tall,
just ended.
I am strong.
Hi.
Whoa.
It's over and over and over again to fucking jail.
He was fucking scream at the top of your lungs.
Just leap off the top of the building.
Did you hear snoop dog is no longer snoop.
Snoop,
lion.
Lion.
Yeah.
You went to Jamaica above.
The black guys can change your names.
It's bad ass.
And they usually have parties to do so like puff daddy.
Remember when he was parked?
Now he's not puff daddy anymore.
Now he's peed.
Diddy prince,
I'm just going to be a symbol.
I'm not even going to be a word.
That was really the best.
Prince was the smoothest move ever because I think that was a contractual thing
that he said that he could then he could make his own music or something because
he couldn't be prince and I don't think he could change his name.
It was like one of those deals because like,
okay,
um,
whew.
Yeah.
Cause you remember he put,
he had slave on his cheek for like a year,
you know.
Well the music companies are there.
Bad motherfuckers [inaudible] Robin rap guy that had the bandaid on this.
Jake?
No,
no,
no.
Our Kelly is getting,
oh Nelly Nelly.
Yeah.
Bad days.
Right.
I wonder if bandaids we keep cool.
I wonder if that's healed.
And it was always on like different parts of his cheek.
Like you,
I switched this guys.
I thought I was in bad shape.
He was so good.
What,
how can we didn't put all your music?
I don't know.
Did he just get to rich and just go crazy?
Spent all his money on.
Well,
and that's always hit with,
with,
with uh,
with rap guys is a,
you know,
when they make too much money then,
then they,
they kinda,
you know,
dude,
who's going to clean my pool is late.
You know,
it's,
it's not as street and loses the message a little bit.
Well now that little Wayne's out of the Pokey,
all that Shit's change my nasal.
Well the whole way you well,
do you follow rap music at all?
Uh,
I like everything music wise,
but yeah,
no,
I um,
I like rap.
Um,
I I interrupted you,
you back.
We were talking about when we first met or when we've met and hung out,
but one of them was when you have that NBC show,
right.
That's what I was saying is that,
you know,
and so it was this,
it was like this,
uh,
there was a lot of pressure.
It was very big time.
Uh,
and NBC had this unveiling of their new shows or,
or all their shows at the Lincoln Center in New York City.
And people are coming across the stage and then like I saw you backstage,
you came up to me and I was just like,
so happy to see a comedian.
Yeah.
You know,
and I,
I think,
you know,
we hung out and talked for most of the night cause like everybody else,
like actors and stuff,
dude,
I felt the exact same way when,
whenever wanting to a real comedian,
it's like,
oh,
you're here.
I wanted to hug you.
Please tell me what's life like in the same sane world you operate in.
When we were not saying,
but we're saying yes
for us,
you know,
like a,
if you run in Doug Stan hope at the airport,
you're so happy.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
yes.
Yeah.
You motherfucker.
I mean,
that's uh,
the glory of being friends with Comedians,
you know,
to have friends like Joey Diaz,
Joey Coco Diaz and you know,
so many of our friends are calm.
I mean,
everybody that we bring around here to the Ice House,
we have these ice house chronical shows.
He got to do one man,
they're so fun.
They're so fun.
You're here at the ice house this weekend,
right?
It's Friday and Saturday nights.
Friday and Saturday.
They've never seen Tom Rhodes.
He's a bad motherfucker.
International comedian or real comics comic dude has been around forever.
And,
uh,
the ice house is probably,
if not the oldest club in the country.
It's right up there.
Yeah.
I'm all these classic comedy albums were recorded here.
Like Bob Newhart the button down mind.
And,
uh,
the smothers brothers.
Um,
I just came out with a new CD and it's a,
it's a double CD thing.
One is live at the comedy store in Sydney,
Australia and the other one is live at the ice house.
Did those comedy stores are like a rip off of the real comedy store?
Right.
They don't pay the real comedy store.
They just
called it the,
there's no,
there are,
none of them are related to the London one.
The Sydney one sneaky international name thieving and motherfuckers taken money
out of Mitzi shore.
His pocket,
I think.
Uh,
she,
no,
that ain't the comedy store.
I think it's one in Japan too.
Right?
Right.
To a bitch.
Oh No.
Come to store.
I think they didn't,
uh,
you know,
copyright the name they fucked up there.
They only copywritten it.
Wrote it in California or the state,
whatever it is.
There's only two real comedy stores in the world,
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's Hollywood and La Jolla.
That's it.
Okay.
Let's not get crazy,
Tom.
I've never been a big comedy comedies for a guy.
Uh,
I just recently,
like this year,
I've done like three sets there.
And,
uh,
that's,
well I,
I've enjoyed going there and hanging out.
Like I think the last time I saw you was there a,
when I ran into a few years ago and you know,
a good friends of mine play there.
Um,
but I always had a strange feeling about the place,
which I'm starting to get over now,
uh,
because I've,
I've enjoyed playing there this year.
But,
uh,
I'm from,
the Orlando Florida area and when I was 19 years old,
I won this contest,
the funniest person in central Florida contest.
Uh,
not funny person in Florida,
funny person in central Florida,
which I think is hilarious.
Um,
there was a kid in south Florida who was a real bad ass.
and the Grand Prize of this contest was I got to go to fly to Los Angeles and do
a set at the comedy store.
And I'm 19 years old,
man.
I've been a comedy for two years.
La the Commons or,
oh my God,
you'd have thought I was doing Johnny Carson.
This is my break,
baby.
Cool in La man.
And in retrospect it was an open mic night and I only did five minutes,
but there was a,
a very famous comedian there.
Uh,
I won't mention the man's name.
and he acted like I was the funniest comedian you've ever seen in his life.
And then he invites,
he a big guy.
I'm not saying Pauly shore.
No,
no,
let's just for the record state who was not Pauly shore?
Uh,
no,
let's go.
Let's,
let's,
uh,
leave some mystery.
Um,
anyway,
um,
so Amy not be a big guy.
He invites me to hang out with him and then he asked me to,
uh,
take a drive with him and Oh my God.
You know,
who wouldn't want to take a drive with famous guy and we'd car car.
We parked in front of,
uh,
the rage on Santa Monica for like 20 minutes and he said he's a bar.
Well,
years later when I lived in La,
I find out the rage is like the biggest gay bar in Los Angeles.
I had no idea at the time.
So this guy is showing off his young meat.
And,
uh,
and then he says he needs to go by his apartment in Beverly Hills.
And,
uh,
we go in and they on his wall,
he had all these photos of him and famous people that were signed in.
And so we go from one side down all the way,
and he's showing me,
you know,
uh,
this is me with Gandhi and Martin Luther King and whatever,
whoever,
or,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
And then we get to the end of the wall and it's the corner.
This was the guys move to show you the pictures.
You start at one side and then boom,
you're in the corner.
And He makes this move on me.
And I'm 19 years old.
And,
and the guy steps in on me and like,
and,
and I just like,
I just like Kinda,
I recoiled and,
and the guy steps in on me,
any,
he cupped my ass.
Oh,
with each hand.
He's got it.
And it asks you why you're afraid to say this man's name.
I don't say it.
Don't,
don't,
I won't say I won't.
I promise you,
I won't say it,
but I will say what it rhymes with.
No,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't,
don't do it.
Please don't.
So anyway,
uh,
you know,
I said,
can we go back to the comedy store and,
um,
I can't help but reflect on that moment all these years later and think how much
further my career would have gone if I would've just fuck to that guy.
I don't think so.
You would lose all your street cred,
kidding,
loose somebody.
Anyway,
but that was why.
So like,
you know,
and I go back to Florida and I'm 19,
and I'm like,
people are like,
hey,
how was your trip to Hollywood?
I don't want to talk.
And uh,
have you talked to him since or sever?
Never seen the guy ever again.
But,
um,
uh,
but yeah,
so that kind of made me Chai away from the comedy store for,
well,
that makes sense.
I didn't know that that guy was doing that,
but it kind of makes sense.
I think a lot of those guys,
you know,
I mean when you hear enough stories about dudes like that,
that the pull moves on misuses and stuff and oh my God,
how about John Travolta?
Man,
you think that's true?
Well you think he really had his ass cause like three or four guys came out and
said that he'd stick his ass up in the air and go,
he touch it.
Oh,
oh I just touched my,
my butthole.
I can only speculate.
Do you think maybe you think maybe he's just at a higher level of Scientology
than we would ever understand?
It could be the queen.
Maybe.
Maybe that's the top level.
You get to stick your ass up at people and beg them to touch it.
We're,
we're seeing as immoral activity is really the next phase of evolution.
And once you really appreciate the,
the pleasure of the prostate gland,
you can move x level of clear.
You can go super leisure of the process.
Super duper clear.
Well,
it's there to secret,
you know that the feelings are secret.
It's the best feeling of all time.
Have someone massage the prostate.
And John Travolta's obviously figured it out,
but these non,
he on the highest,
no is the highest level.
These people who are all delusional,
he should be able to pay,
especially as an upper level superman character in the fucking game of
Scientology.
He should be able to pay to get his asshole rob.
Right?
Why is leisure?
Why is he going to strangers?
Because we got a lot of talent.
Tails.
Two chasse pitches out there working in massage powers needing to learn to keep
they trap shed,
right?
I mean,
Hey,
what,
what happened to Mizzou?
Client
potentiality.
Listen,
every comedian knows due to steal jokes.
Every Massoud should know a celebrity that wants you to finger in her asshole.
It's part
of your job,
man.
You should know what's dangerous.
You know what I'm saying?
If you want to be a UFC fighter,
don't play footsies with hootsuite Maher.
Paul Harris,
you know what I'm saying?
I uh,
watched an info commercial last night called them Milan abroad.
Have you heard of this thing?
Milan abroad?
I think the drr yeah,
I think there's all the old UFC,
a ring girl was in it,
but it's weird because it was,
it was such a man bashing commercial.
First it starts off like saying like is your abroad doing this and that and
they're showing all these really luscious hot girls and then they showed this
bra and it's just like the most ugliest,
grossest thing.
And it's like hide that cleavage abroad was designed by men,
you know,
and like,
and then they did like that fake game show thing where they have like a studio
audience.
Like now did a man make this?
No,
this is the way women should look.
Anyways,
I just found it on youtube.
Just to show you a little example of how insane this is.
A,
if it's called the Milana brawl by Jeannie,
spell it.
Mulana having another bad broad day,
shoulders drafts and hot shower,
digging in hooks,
poking you in the back and bras that just don't look at this talk was really
commercials.
Introducing the Milan abroad by Jeannie,
designed by a woman for women.
This amazing bra gives you super support,
amazing lift and incredible comfort.
All in a beautiful hands.
Don't lace Cammie style.
Say Goodbye to painful straps that are digging into your shoulders.
See if you see the full commercial art,
it's on late night TV.
It will make you so pissed off at like at like what they say.
And you could just tell.
It's like,
like,
why would,
why do you want to show your cleavage?
You know,
don't,
don't give into the man and stuff like that.
Get them a know.
What I think they're saying is that that other shit is uncomfortable,
uncomfortable.
Underarm bulge disappears and you've somehow or another turn that into a man
versus woman thing.
Embarrassing cleavage and God
sexy classically which bits?
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
It's always there.
That sounds very,
very smooth.
So I'm happy about that.
It's the one broad,
oh,
shut these ladies.
I don't want to hear about that will drive you crazy.
But anyways,
I think the first part is awesome.
I think it's just the old UFC girl rate.
Let me see if I can find it.
Uh,
nevermind.
I'll find it.
Don't hurt right there.
Yeah,
probably.
it does.
A lot of those.
She's,
yeah,
that's Shondelle.
Yeah,
she does a lot of modeling.
Unfortunately.
She did some,
some new type stuff at one point in time.
Isn't that what we all expect from your ring girl?
Yeah.
You're allowed to do certain levels of nude type stuff.
I don't know,
just to me,
but no whole closeup.
No animals.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
I just think it's so crazy.
People are so Weirdo when it comes to that shit.
Especially now with technology and teenagers with so I'm so glad.
Like cell phones went around like camera phones when I was a teenager.
It'd be hours online.
We do an hour long films.
We like really got lucky.
We missed that.
I know,
but I mean like there's so many girls,
uh,
you know,
taking pictures of their snatches.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well there,
there's horrible hacks have happened in like,
I think that'll be the new fingerprinting system in the future.
You know how people have those accounts where you can upload pictures from your
cell phone when people have hacked into those and got a lot of girls like secret
photos of Weikel loads on their faces.
America.
Well,
you know,
like that,
that,
that uh,
Rupert Murdoch's sons scandal in England.
I mean,
no wonder like if it,
what does that scandal where like they hacked into people's email accounts and
that they were also,
they were eavesdropping on celebrity's phone calls and they could retrieve,
um,
uh,
their voice mails and things.
That's incredible.
So I mean,
like,
I,
you know,
Rupert Murdoch got in trouble for that.
That was the show,
the data.
They'd also,
there was a girl who had been abducted and killed and then he got her voice
messages but also like cute brands and all these people,
they were like,
you know,
listening to what happened to his phone calls.
They checked the message and it gave the family hope that she was still alive.
That was it.
They knew that the phone,
that someone had checked since then,
like,
oh,
she's alive.
She's alive.
Right,
right,
right.
I mean,
miles,
she wasn't alive.
That's some creepy shit,
man.
They ghoulish you know,
and so how come he's not in jail?
Oh,
he's really funny.
He's really super rich.
Super,
super,
super rich.
Yeah.
If that was Tom Rhodes,
Tom Rhodes,
you'd be in jail right now and then amazing.
And we just sort of,
it like,
well he is super rich and we still live in like a king era when it's still
really like that.
If you're lazy.
When he was in court,
some guy,
uh,
I was in Europe,
so I saw some guy who came in with the Pi and smashed the pine,
his face.
But his,
his,
uh,
his Asian wife jumped up and deck to the guy.
It was like,
do you think it's even possible to like take Bill Gates to court?
You know what I mean?
To like prosecute him with some sort of a crime.
Could you,
could you ever go after him?
He's,
he,
when you have that kind of money,
I mean,
isn't it possible like stop everything in its tracks?
Like,
could Rupert Murdoch go to jail?
They ever,
could.
You ever see him being arrested and never had,
especially since he doesn't live in America,
right?
It doesn't even live in Australia.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's Australian,
but um,
but doesn't live in him.
He knows where he lives.
He lives wherever it lives on top of Mount Everest,
the probably lives everywhere.
Sons.
It's probably got a house and every state just drives into that shit son.
You got Rupert Murdoch,
top money.
That guy's not going to jail now.
He's probably got a,
you know,
a farm of,
um,
poor people that he's going to start you taking their organs as he gets older.
Yeah,
that's probably clones.
It's probably a headless versions of him.
You know,
they're going to chop his old head off and stick on some super young body.
Right.
It's going to be awesome.
You want to be like 70 from the neck up and 20,
20 young people get the card is a rock.
People guessed the comic.
No,
they didn't.
they didn't Brian.
All right.
No,
they didn't.
Did they?
No.
No,
that's right.
They didn't
say that it would,
they didn't.
Right.
They didn't do it on this.
A lot of them got it wrong.
Right on my space.
Yeah.
They got it wrong everywhere.
Brian,
you don't want to get sued by that guy.
Totally.
Plus he'll corner you.
He's got moves.
He's got traps set up all around the city,
forever conversations with you.
Can we just walk over here and have a boom?
Next thing you know,
um,
the,
uh,
the trap,
the trap was masterful.
It was really amazing.
Who's is with the famous [inaudible],
the playmaker
David Lee Roth,
that is a,
his mansion in Pasadena.
And he had his gold records from the front door up the staircase to the bedroom.
So when he would bring women over,
I mean,
this might just be,
you know,
um,
he's an urban mythology,
but even come in and go,
oh,
let me show you my gold records and then boom,
we're in the bedroom.
So I mean,
masterful.
I mean,
that might be bullshit,
but change shit.
He's got Damn David Lee Roth believable.
Let's talk about excesses.
Gabe.
David Lee Roth man grabs a hero.
There was a,
there was a story.
Uh,
Paul Williams,
I guess.
And remember Paul Williams is a little guy and hoser yeah,
singer.
I think it was Paul Williams and like some friends of Johnny Carson's this
little men's drinking group in the 70s where they,
they in,
this might be urban mythology as well,
but,
uh,
it's a great story.
I heard years ago that they would try and top each other like,
uh,
doing a special lunch for each other and like,
just the most extravagant,
you know,
rich guy,
shit they could think of and that,
uh,
they,
they stopped playing the game.
I forget who it was,
but like,
somebody that,
you know,
that it sends limos to get all six of the guys or whatever,
and they'd go to the,
you know,
Burbank airport or wherever and like,
there's like six helicopters waiting and they fly out and there's like a,
uh,
a prostitute in each helicopter who handed them a bag lunch with a sandwich and
then the helicopter hovered over each guy's house and their wives are probably,
and they got to eat the sandwich and get a blow job
as the helicopter hovered over their house.
That's beautiful.
And then like whoever was in charge that,
okay,
that'll never be topped some James Bond type awesomeness.
That's bad ass.
That's why it's worth it to become a fucking billionaire.
Yeah.
Rupert Murdoch probably has like buttons and he presses and chicks come out of
the fridge [inaudible] naked chicks and they just suck his cock.
He probably has it set up like little spring traps everywhere in the house and
he forgets about them once in a while and even though we've got our dead one and
if I want a blow job I will press this button.
She appears in the bathroom.
Yeah.
So right when he's about to honey,
I'll be right back.
It's going to take a shit.
She pops out of the floor and it's in a capsule wash.
Like those things.
They hadn't star Trek.
She does.
The floor rises like a half a second.
She's already underneath and they could,
he just shoves his cock in her mouth.
Boom.
I was thinking,
I was thinking last night there was so many hot Asian girls that we should have
like a discount of your hot Asian.
Greg get $5 off your ticket or something.
Shut up bro.
Fuck.
If he wanted to do that route from where I wanted to do that,
he could have it set up where it's where he takes a shit because no woman ever
want to walk in on an old man was taking a shit and old men start shitting.
All you have to do is say,
all right,
I don't want to take a shit.
And he could just have,
no one would ever know if he had some offset tile.
If he had some really interesting tile and just had you know,
a good,
you know,
weird geometrical design that this,
this capsule was made out of and then you know,
he'd do that.
Have them waiting.
You'd have them waiting.
You know,
maybe you had like a little iPhone app,
maybe has a little iPhone 6:00 PM in the shitter and it just shows up.
Shuts that.
Checking your Twitter again.
Yeah,
I like it recognized and when he's in the room and maybe he has a chip and in
his arm so that every room it goes into the right lighting and mood light comes
on,
walks in that bathroom.
They know it's him hook her out of the floor.
I mean when that would be amazing if he could really pull it off and no one knew
and then you're like,
you get there like later on he dies and they find out he was like a Nazi or some
crazy shit.
So they have to go through his house.
I know his wife is like 40 years younger than him and when the media goes
through his house,
they find these capsules and they were they,
they led to this underground tunnels that led to an airplane runway when they
would bring girls to write from Thailand and they would just go into the
capsules.
They didn't even know where they were.
They were blindfolded,
the whole flight.
They were just brought in as Rupert Murdoch's bathroom suckers.
Have you actually really ever had your Dick Suck?
Whoa.
On the toilet?
No,
that's pretty gross.
That's pretty good.
That's so rude to make someone smell your shit and suck your Dick.
You greedy bitch.
Dana would one or the other?
Yeah,
maybe Dana would,
but yeah.
How funny was that?
Last night we had a,
a podcast,
the icehouse chronicles of a dandy or Oman and dom Arrera knew everything about
her.
It was,
oh,
Tom's the best jobs at this.
Those a woman.
Yeah,
Dom's the best.
She's a confirmed program from the get go.
Yeah.
He said like what?
Tell stories about which crazy chick he was living with.
It was that one crazy stripper.
You remember that one jail.
It was like,
as opposed to which one wasn't a crazy stripper
that where we're already,
he's,
he's like,
he's a real deal.
You know?
I love knowing that this is a guy like that out there.
Right?
He's a guy like Tom or were still write new material.
So yeah,
we had them at the ice house.
Joey Diaz.
Dot.
Merera.
That was Brody Stevenson.
Dom Irrera is a mother of Craig show.
Hillar crushed it.
I watched him crush it on a Friday night on a Wednesday night.
I mean,
he always nails it and it's like,
it's so inspiring to see that he's always writing.
You know?
I love that.
I love my seat.
He's always got a fucking notebook with him.
It's always going over some shit before he goes on.
Some dudes just somewhere along the line,
they just kind of like give up on that.
Right.
Not
Him.
Tom Dahmer's out there slinging.
I love that when you see older guys still care and still put the work in.
I'm friends with uh,
it's a real common friends with rich hall and he's,
and he's in London and you see him and you're like,
God,
it's,
yeah,
he's fantastic.
He was one of the guys I paid to see before ever did comedy.
I saw him at a stitches Comedy Club in Boston,
Massachusetts,
like right before I did my first open mic night.
It was cool.
He was him and this Guy Teddy Burger performed Teddy Burger on.
Was this a local headliner who was a brilliant,
brilliant comedian who really never got his,
it never really,
it never got his notoriety because he had a problem with drugs and alcohol and
all kinds of shit.
He's like a legend back in Boston.
I mean,
just amazing,
amazing comedian.
And I saw a ritual.
Denise,
what was his,
I remember he played in Orlando when I was at like open miker and uh,
he had a lot of props.
He came out,
he had like a tricycle and there was a car door welded to it.
Yeah.
And he like he'd rolled down the window and he leaned out the,
it was like really cute stuff.
Yeah.
He had a lot of weird niblets but um,
but yeah,
no,
he's like,
what was this niglets though?
Explained those were words for things that there are no words,
like belly button lint and all these different sites around the milk carton
night falls off into your cereal.
Every time you on screen paste it sticks to the sink.
And,
um,
but he's actually,
you know,
very political,
social minded comedian now he's,
is it really?
Yeah.
And you see him and it's,
I mean he's,
you know,
like that was the thing about miles Davis.
He,
um,
he had like seven or eight different styles in the course of his career and
that's Kinda like rich hall is,
you know,
gotta be on his ninth style of comedy.
So he's doing it in London now.
Plays theaters all over England.
Yeah.
Didn't he?
How many farm and like British Columbia,
he's got a ranch in Montana.
Montana.
Yeah,
that's right.
I went out and stayed with him a couple of years ago for the month of August
ranch in Montana because I know Harris Pete from the comedy store was a buddy of
his and Harris piece to do stuff with them out in the ranch.
Yeah.
He's got,
he's got a really easy thing to have a ranch in Montana.
Right.
That's legit.
That is legit.
That's big sky said.
It's so beautiful out there.
And he's got,
he's got a,
uh,
a pitching machine set up in his,
in his endless backyard.
And so we would sit and he loves it in Montana's beautiful.
Uh,
and,
and so we would sit in his backyard for just hours smacking the shit out of
baseballs.
And that's all I was like,
you know,
when you're a kid and you think,
oh man,
if I ever get a lot of money,
I'm going to have a batting machine in my backyard,
you know?
But,
well,
I mean,
Montana is most certainly beautiful.
Don't get me wrong.
But why did he pick that as opposed to like Wyoming,
Colorado?
Like what,
what about Montana appealed to him?
I,
it's stunning.
There.
I the,
you know,
the area is Livingston and it's just,
it's,
it's breathtaking.
You know?
What else is amazing?
They're very,
there's a lot of cool,
I think a Jeff Bridges lives there.
Peter Fonda lives there.
There's a lot of,
you think you can hang out with them if you live there?
I
think,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
uh,
Walter Kearns is writer who wrote up in the air.
Um,
you know,
this is a small town.
Everybody knows each other,
you know,
so we're on is sitting on his,
uh,
on his porch,
people coming by and,
you know,
it's awesome.
Hmm.
Um,
I actually hit a deer and I had to stay a week longer than I had anticipated.
And I always thought that kind of makes you hit a deer.
Yeah.
My car was,
uh,
the whole front end was smashed and repaired.
Yeah,
I could,
it was undrivable wow.
But,
and it was like four o'clock in the afternoon.
Really Sunny,
beautiful day.
I always thought that kind of thing happened at night and I was only going like
45,
uh,
I was just building up momentum.
I had just turned on this road and it was actually kind of beautiful to see this
gorgeous creature up close like that as it bounced off my hood.
It's like this really radiant a red brown coat.
Yeah.
We're so removed from the variety of nature that a deer is like some shit from
Avatar,
you know,
it's alive.
Look,
Like we control all the animals in our perimeter.
That's why we're able to like walk down streets or bear fleshy acids.
We don't have to worry about elks ramming us and shit.
We sort of control the perimeters.
We keep the animals out with all this hard surface and craziness.
But deers are supposed to be around people.
It's like that's what you're supposed to be their food.
You're supposed to live around them.
Yes.
You got to have a good bumper though,
man.
You ever see those bumpers that they make for trucks?
That's why everybody has trucks there and I,
you know,
not just trucks.
They have oh spit specific type of bumper.
Right.
Rock CV.
Pull it up Brian.
Cause it's like some road warrior type Shit.
They've a cleaver bumper cars knock them down.
Yeah.
Well if you hit it with this bumper,
deflects it to the left or to the right.
You know,
the idea is that you can really get fucked up by a deer,
especially in elk.
Do you hit an elk hills?
There are a moose,
Moose or mass.
I saw a huge pickup truck there that it hit him loose and it was,
it was mangled.
The whole big crush fall,
like a shoe.
Aluminum canners there's so huge man.
And they're so stupid in this bumper.
They had to go and I'm talking about,
is that what it's called?
I don't know now the deer slaughterer look at the big lights to on the front of
it.
That shit's also important.
Did you know semis?
The front tires of semis have like,
like spikes coming out of them.
What?
I'd never knew like the uh,
on the,
on the hubcap?
Yeah,
on the hub.
I've never noticed this before.
I just started noticing it yesterday.
They have like these Mad Max spinning or James Bond,
like not all of them.
I think that's like a,
a special,
that's like getting rims on your car.
You know,
if you're a trucker I think,
oh it's sexy.
But I noticed that like,
I noticed it yesterday and I noticed every truck in la at least has it and I won
is that just so if anyone tries to come over on them that they just like
destroyed the car before the semi,
before the semi loses its fire guys Mad Max.
Probably Pretty Smart.
I'd probably be like that rather than,
you know,
I'd rather your car get a little fucked up in this semi,
lose a tire and go careening into
a crowd.
Yeah.
I never noticed that prosthetic was mad max.
The road warrior.
It's,
they're fighting each other for gasoline and comfortably as it gets closer,
big guy that I am the humongous and then his gay lover with the Mohawk gets the,
uh,
bet,
whatever you call it,
the boomerang in the head.
Remember that it could go that way.
If you,
uh,
if you look at parts of the world like Liberia where it's like a really badly
fucked up area of the world,
especially during the civil war,
which was not that long ago,
Liberia where we sent the freed slaves that wanted to go back to after I quit.
I mean horrific.
Their capital is Monrovia or you know a lot about Liberia.
I know a lot of them have watched that Vice.
Dot.
You are fucking international man.
You are Tom Rhodes.
Did you ever watch that?
Um,
vice guide to travel on Liberia.
The,
they covered that guy.
General button naked.
The guy who was a born again Christian,
who was killed,
thousands and thousands of people murdered children,
ate their heart and shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
Really intense civil war type shit.
And then became like a Christian found Jesus and apparently they like get them
off the a with a child's heart.
Do you drink red or white wine?
I think it just take it raw like a shot.
Well,
no ice.
Nothing.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's so twisted that this guy gets to say,
I,
you know,
I found Jesus.
Now I'm good.
And they forgave and then all your sins are,
yeah.
I mean,
he's like a incredible war criminal and he used to fight naked.
Just took off all his clothes.
That's why you look like Arrow button naked.
Yeah.
That was just,
that was his deal.
Just kill people naked.
Tet personally responsible for the deaths.
Okay.
I never thought I would actually watched this documentary last night.
Uh,
and if you haven't seen it,
you should watch it.
It's called the century of self.
I have heard,
uh,
I like,
you know,
traveling all the time and uh,
I love watching like BBC documentaries,
but free online documentaries and this things called century of self.
And it's about this Guy Edward Bernays,
who was Sigmund Freud's nephew and he,
uh,
after World War One,
he wanted to do,
uh,
propaganda for a interested in controlling the masses,
but he changed,
uh,
propaganda to public relations.
And this guy did,
um,
he got like women to smoke,
like the women suffered,
suffered,
get music movement and women trying to vote.
Uh,
women didn't smoke cigarettes.
It was really a taboo thing.
And then he got these women delight up at this March and they called them
torches of freedom.
And then now we're equal to men.
We can smoke.
And just like a,
just all these things about manipulating the masses through,
um,
you know,
public relations.
And
Yeah,
well they've been doing that since the get go.
As soon as people figured out how to talk,
they figured out that they can lie,
you know,
you don't have to tell the truth and then they just get better and better at it.
And it evolved like everything else.
Well it's interesting.
It's like a four part series.
Like for it's like an hour each thing.
I think the BBC made it,
but then like the last episode is how it's used in politics.
How,
you know this,
uh,
the corporation's learned this at the turn of the,
you know,
how
they could,
cause people used to only buy things that they wanted,
uh,
or that they needed.
And then now you know,
there to fulfill their selfish desires of,
you know,
this product will complete me.
Well,
what happens is people get caught up in this,
this materialism loop where that is the focus where it's constantly attaining
the newest objects,
become the focus and everything else becomes secondary.
It's like the focus is most on,
I got to get this new Ferrari,
there's a new Ferrari out the Ferrari two,
five,
eight Italia.
It is the shit.
I have this car,
it completes me.
I need this car,
I must have this car.
And then you get that car and you know,
you think now you think you're looking at Lamborghini's like Lamborghinis or
more bad ass.
And then,
you know,
you're looking at the fucking véronique and you,
you're getting crazy.
You're,
you're,
you're focusing on objects instead of actual,
I think suit of,
I think you're hanging out with a higher class of people than I not even talking
to.
I'm talking about any human being that does that.
I mean,
like real extreme materialists.
I obviously took it,
uh,
you know,
I took it from Ferrari to it,
but it doesn't have to be that.
It can be a fucking Mustang.
It could be a new TV.
It could be a new computer.
It could be we somehow or another be can become obsessed with attaining some
sort of a new object.
The galaxy s three is out.
Have you tried it?
You know,
it becomes like the focus of your fucking day.
You're watching all these youtube reviews on the galaxy s three,
and you're like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I have a phone.
Why am I being so crazy?
What am I doing here?
Am I going to use all these features?
Have you seen the galaxy answer?
Who Cares?
How dare you?
It looks pretty sporty.
It looks like those droid things to finally caught up to iPhones and they even
passed him in a lot of ways.
Nope,
you don't think so?
Yeah.
Like you,
like if you paid attention,
Jude,
just,
just being after shows,
getting,
you know,
talking to all these people that have their different phones and asking them
every,
every single time I go,
so do you like it?
Do you like a lot?
And he goes,
yeah,
I mean I want an iPhone,
but I just can't afford it.
And I'm like,
I get that,
you know,
that's cool.
You can't afford it.
It is more expensive.
But what really sucks is just like using these people's cameras,
like the cause of everyone wants to take a photo and stuff so you get to seed
like photo afterwards.
So we pretty much are the best Beta testers or just a to play with shows for
cell phones.
And every time I'm like real pretty interested.
Like,
let me see what the photo looks like.
You know,
let's do this.
And it's,
it's always shit shit.
Especially like those,
uh,
those sprint ones,
those HTCs are fucking terrible.
It's all blurred out and shit.
But I'll tell you,
um,
I did see someone take a picture with one of those galaxy threes and it was bad
ass.
I mean,
I,
I wouldn't,
if somebody gave me one,
I would use it for a month.
And you know,
there's a commercial
no,
that note that.
Um,
have you seen the,
um,
the,
the note,
it's called a second.
What is it?
A Samsung note?
Yeah.
It's just like a scene.
It's a smaller iPads.
It's ridiculous.
It looks awesome.
Fits in your pocket.
It's the shit.
I'm like,
I gotta get one.
I must have it.
See what's weird now like traveling,
I just spent two months playing all over Europe and uh,
I had a week off.
I went to Rome and you see people with their I pads and
taking them around and taking photos,
videos.
It's really weird to be like the coliseum and see somebody,
the new big ass iPad.
Yeah,
the new iPads camera in it is really,
really good.
Is it really?
What is a how many megabytes?
Hd Video Camera.
Well then that exists.
So it's,
that's minimal,
but they're there.
You know,
it's a skinny little thing and it's got an awesome,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's 96 degrees in Rome.
It's hot and especially the coliseum and the ancient ruins.
And you got this,
you know,
uh,
electronics don't like moisture,
right?
But if you did have one of those things and you were walking around with it like
that,
they,
they know what the fuck they're doing when they make these,
they're not going to fuck up with moisture,
but you're going to get some amazing pictures.
You're you to be able to see it on a big screen,
a big iPad screen.
I could see that because a lot of times you take a picture of something as
spectacular as the coliseum.
You don't exactly know what you got.
Have you taken with an Ipad,
you know exactly what you got.
That's kind of bad ass to think of just that alone.
If they eventually get it to a point where you don't need a real camera,
like they can get the the technology down.
I don't know if it's really possible.
We don't need extending lens or anything nutty like that.
That would be the perfect thing.
You take pictures with an Ipad,
you can see what the fuck your picture looks like.
I think the,
that we're going to see what the next iPhone is.
A another smaller note.
Do you think so type IPAD,
there's already been a lot of rumors that they're going to have like a seven
inch iPad,
which it would be kind of like around the notes size or is it seven inches?
I don't know.
I don't have no idea,
but I just compare everything to my deck.
There's bigger than that.
It's about half the size of it and I know my Dick is bigger than this right
here.
It's really incredible that,
you know,
just to have the,
access to all of human knowledge in your hand.
Like we were talking before we started,
like,
it's a great thing about smart phones is you're talking to somebody now and
you're like,
oh,
what's the fastest bird?
Uh,
uh,
yeah.
I mean it's like the,
or somebody at a bar talking shit,
you know,
and you can cannonball one cannon ball three won best actor.
Whether you're like,
yeah,
fuck you,
let's go to the answer machine and you look it up.
We love doing that on the podcast is the coolest thing.
When you were like,
who the fuck do you,
was that one right?
Like I was saying,
but like I was saying about the torture songs.
Exactly.
I mean,
remember years ago,
like if you needed to like make a phone call and you're driving on the highway,
you had to like get off on the exit,
find a pay phone with aids on it,
uh,
you know,
call some number,
right.
Where you really
worried that you could possibly catch aids from a phone.
You know,
like when aids first came out,
you're like,
what if it's on this?
What if the agent is on things?
Like,
what if it's like the flu,
right?
Yeah.
I remember like in it like recently it's come out,
uh,
the,
the in the,
in the news that,
you know,
we're,
we're kind of close not to eradicating it fully,
but like to really minimizing it,
um,
where it's not a threat to the,
to the whole human population.
Like what,
when we were teenagers,
Jesus that came out and yeah.
Do you remember when Kennison came out with a joke about it?
He goes,
okay.
oh yeah.
They say,
Sam Hayes is a communicable disease.
Heterosexual people die with too.
He goes,
name on fucking guy.
It's not our dance.
I'm like,
whoa.
Holy Shit.
Sam was the best.
He was my favorite ever.
Sam was great man.
Who's the best,
he's the most to me,
the,
I mean,
Richard Pryor's probably really the best,
but Sam was one of my favorites.
I mean right up there with prior to me,
just like,
just not,
I mean,
if you have to like say who's the better comments and those priorities,
the front yard doing,
working on the yard,
just shoot me dry run or just kill me.
I'm in hell.
You got to say prioritize better because Sam would have never been Sam if prior
heading to come first.
You know,
they,
you had to have a guy like that,
like prior had to have a guy like Lenny Bruce,
you know,
Sam had to have a guy like prior.
Yeah.
You have to somebody who shows you the way,
like every one of us is sort of piggy backing on everybody else's,
you know,
we're all sort of Hicks,
disciples and some sort of a way.
Right.
But I mean,
I remember doing comedy in Florida at first few years and you know,
um,
there was just a lot of bland,
generic,
you know,
white guys.
And then Florida,
there was a lot of New York,
uh,
acts,
it would come down in the winter and they are all like,
you know,
uh,
they did a lot of talking to the crowd and,
you know,
hey,
when you're on the subway,
no,
we're in Florida.
We don't have a subway.
Well that's city.
God I remember,
but I remember that it was just like this kind of,
um,
kinda eighties hacking enos.
And then,
uh,
it was the comedian Ron Bennington,
he's on Sirius now.
Love Ron Ben.
He was like the first beast of a comedian I saw.
He was so brilliant,
man.
Like the first guy I ever saw talking about like things that mattered and I saw
him and that like opened my eyes like,
wow,
you can actually talk about shit that matters.
And then,
um,
maybe a year later or something Kinison exploded.
And like,
those were the first two guys I saw where I was like,
wow,
this is,
you can approach this.
You don't have to,
uh,
you know,
pander to the,
to the masses.
You can talk about real shit that matters.
Heard about Kennison from a girl I was working with was a chick I worked with
the Boston Athletic Club.
She saw Kinison on Hbo.
She said it was so fun and she came to work the next day and was was reenacting
his bit about the homosexual necrophilia acts were having sex with the gay with
the dead corpses.
Oh,
it was really funny.
She was doing it in the parking lot.
It was so funny watching her do it that I had a checkout Kennison and that was,
I was 19 and that was the first seed that was planted in my head.
I remember thinking like,
Whoa,
like this is comedy too.
I never thought this could be like this guy was for folks who don't understand,
but for Kennison came along,
there was nothing even remotely like that.
A guy who just would scream just like,
yeah,
I was married.
I hope you slide that club,
man.
I hope you slide your door a gas truck and takes your own [inaudible].
It's fine.
His
pain was so awesome.
It was like,
here's this guy who was just so completely different than anybody had ever seen
before.
A former preacher,
he's fat short and cares all fucked up.
He wears a hat,
he wears a bra,
totally confident,
covers his body in a trench coat,
walks on the stage with sneakers on and just just dominates.
You just dominates the room from the moment he gives us that,
you can't wait to hear what this guy's going to say.
No.
Oh my God.
And then like,
you know,
in Florida and the southern United States or areas,
so like,
you know,
I'm heavy Christian,
Jesus freaks and that stuff.
He would,
you know,
be talking about Jesus jokes about,
well he had the most cloud of anybody who was an actual cause.
He was a pastor.
Yeah.
So for,
they couldn't fuck with them when it came to like biblical verses.
And should he get away with shit that a guy like you or I might not and you
know,
might not be able to pull things out of it.
He pulled the vedic,
gets out of his ass,
he fucking taught it,
which is amazing.
It's just what a what a crazy life.
You know,
they say he was normal until he got hit by a car.
Don't really see it as a really shy kid.
Got Hit by a car,
became a completely different person.
His book,
his brother wrote a book about it called on my brother Sam.
Not a book about his whole life,
but about the,
I think it was a truck that hit him when he was a little boy and it just,
whatever pops up and loose and away we go.
We got Sam Kinison in the world of comedy has changed by maybe a kid getting hit
by a truck,
you know,
that might have been what it was.
They say a lot of times when people get head trauma,
they get really reckless.
They get crazy.
Yeah.
Well there's that famous,
a psychological thing.
It was,
I think it was in Connecticut or New Hampshire or something like in the,
like a hundred years ago.
Some guy who was a really nice guy in the village and he,
he was at work and this big metal pole went through his brain and he lived and
something happened to him where he like,
his whole personality changed where he became like,
just like a,
a huge alcoholic asshole.
Really mean guy or just this,
a brain trauma just completely changed his personality.
Well,
there was a story in one of those London tabloids and then some people get hit
and then they speak fluent French.
I don't know if the story was true,
but there was a guy who,
uh,
was a rugby player and something happened to him.
He got knocked unconscious and you don't believe it.
We talked about this before and we looked at photos and he looked gay before
also see that he was like on the fence.
Well that's what they,
he says that it made them gay and he woke up and you know,
he had no desire to be with women anymore.
Number eight under the government was working on that like gay bomb.
Yes.
Would it have been great if that would have worked?
I mean great.
Like all our enemies,
we just dropped this gay bomb on him and we were going,
everybody starts making out.
That would be that they couldn't have perfected that turn Iraq into a big just
gay bar.
Just a big gay hoedown.
They changed their,
their national anthem to it's raining men.
What a ridiculous idea that they thought they were going to develop a bog gate
box that you could check off and it would turn people,
the turn the soldiers on themselves and the idea was be that it would kill
morale because they would just be bought fucking each other in the trenches and
they would just give up.
When we came with guns,
they probably did
create it and they probably let it loose,
but it's such a homophobic idea because you're saying that a man is,
is in capable of fighting if he's been kind of become,
becomes a homosexual.
That's the idea is that you moralize them.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think it made like men instantly desirable was the thing.
Well,
yeah,
but also the idea was that they would be demoralized,
they would start having sex with their,
their,
you know,
coworkers.
That was the idea.
Like that was so by [inaudible] pretty prevalent in the Middle East.
Anyway,
I think they say men boys or for fun.
Women are for procreation.
Yeah,
I've heard that before.
Is that really true?
Yeah,
I think there's a,
that's a big deal.
I know people in Afghanistan,
I've,
I've talked to,
I talk to my brother was over there and that's,
yeah,
that's a very common to what I heard.
Yeah.
That's a mess.
There's a lot of the,
of the world's really fucking a lot of,
yeah.
And then,
you know,
you talk to people and they're complaining here.
It's like,
oh,
player.
Nice Pasadena.
Nice.
It is out here.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous,
isn't it?
So there's parts of the world where the apocalypse exists.
It's going on right now.
I did a Gig in east Donia country dropper,
uh,
about a month and a half ago and it's really cool up there.
It's right underneath Finland and um,
it's the second least religious country in the world after China really.
And it looks,
it looks like Hitler's wet dream up there.
Everybody's just tall and blonde and really good looking.
A Skype was developed in east Donia apparently,
and it really interesting,
um,
cool people and very intelligent people.
It was awesome to,
um,
perform there.
What was the point in this story?
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
east Odeon was awesome.
Oh No,
that's the second least a religious country in the world.
Then there was like a,
I get in the,
in the main square,
in a,
in,
in Estonia,
um,
there was this church choir of young teenagers and there they were singing like,
you know,
happy praise Jesus songs.
And somebody gave,
uh,
gave me a pamphlet and they were going to the church and I'm filming stuff
constantly in my,
in my travels,
cause I like,
you know,
I'm obsessed with making these little youtube travel videos and stuff and
channel,
uh,
King of Haha or Haha,
just Tom Rhodes search Tom Rhodes,
it'll pop.
R,
h,
o,
d and uh,
these kids were from Pasadena.
They're like,
Eh,
I couldn't believe it.
They were from Pasadenan,
you know,
Baptist Church or whatever,
and they were in Estonia.
He's stony in converting souls.
Oh.
Also they were already missionaries singing happy Jesus songs in the main
square.
We had a kid on the,
a fear factor wants that was a missionary and he would go over to South America
and try to convert people.
Yeah.
Like they would,
uh,
they would go there.
He was a Mormon Mormon missionary,
kind of crazy show up and really poor places.
And you know,
listen,
I know you live in a really hot jungle,
but would you consider wearing these under way?
I want to tell you about a man named Joseph Smith.
He's 14 years old and he found golden tablets that were the last work of Jesus
and only he could read them because he had a magic rock.
Anyway.
Well,
I wasn't the,
wasn't there a talking lizard?
No,
it was a seer stone.
He looked through a seer stone.
A stone.
A magic stone maybe was,
I thought that was a talking to like a white salamander or something.
Really?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe that too,
but I didn't last works.
And the Mormons believe that black people did not go to heaven until they got an
NBA team.
And then I'm like,
I think like what I said true.
Apparently I'll tell you why they don't like the until like,
you know,
like the mid seventies,
they,
Mormons are really nice people.
That's one of the things that they're really,
their religion does do is it supports a sense of community,
uh,
supports banding together.
That's the Mormons I know are extremely a good quality people.
Well,
I have some friends that are Mormons and you have never met and they're,
they're wealthy.
You have never met more charitable people.
They've had,
they've literally had homeless people stay on their property like that.
And then they're wealthy people.
They bring in people off the street and they're,
they're constantly trying to provide anyone who's connected with the church,
with a,
a means to a better life,
to give people jobs.
They help people out.
They drive people to the airport.
I mean,
they're like,
they're super charitable,
nice people.
Right.
And I think that a genealogy,
um,
library of Congress they have in Salt Lake City is like the most comprehensive,
tracking of ancestry on the planet.
It's too bad you can't have that,
have this idea of being a Mormon without all the looney tooney shit.
It's like,
can we just have like a sense of community and being cool to each other and nice
to each other and all be based on love and not have all this wacky Joseph Smith
from 1820 shit where it's like what?
Golden tablets?
No,
that,
this is not the law.
The American Indians are not a lost tribe of Israel.
No,
they're not.
That's crazy.
Like they already checked.
They've done like day,
like a guy who was a Mormon,
spent a fuck load of money to get the,
the,
you know,
the DNA mapped of the American Indian.
It's all there.
Asians that come from side,
they're tall coming down from the,
it's amazing that they can test DNA until we're,
all of your ancestry comes from and what parts of the world.
It's amazing.
Did you see that shit they found in Antarctica?
Did you see the Shit Brown?
No,
they found a fucking rain for it.
Send her the ice in Antarctica.
Wow.
Workshop.
Yeah,
Dude.
Antarctica used to be a Gundam rainforest.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
they're gonna find any like animals there that are frozen.
Well,
I mean you're
talking about miles of ice.
I mean,
I think they're just,
they're just starting to dig into certain spots on it.
And I'm,
I'm gonna try to find it here because it's,
it's a really amazing story,
but they're saying that it used to be like 75 fucking degrees there.
It was like a Pacific northwest.
It was like fucking,
you know,
it was like living in a,
in,
in Oregon or Seattle or something like that and that this was what Antarctica
was like a certain amount of time ago.
It's amazing when you really stop to think about that,
that people were living there at some point in time,
you know,
like primitive people,
no doubt.
But,
and then they had to get the fuck out of there.
The whole thing changed way before anybody invented cars way before any of that
shit.
Yeah.
It says a once covered by less vegetarian poem like trees waved in the breeze.
What,
that's fucking nuts man.
I mean,
wrap your fucking head around that man.
I need to visit the little podcasters get in their fellow go down there and to
the left last door on the left.
And that's cool.
Yeah,
it's amazing man.
But I think they,
they suspected this,
a lot of um,
scientist suspect this,
we actually talked about this on the icehouse chronicles,
the uh,
the maps.
They have these uh,
really old maps from like the 15 hundreds,
I forget the name of the map,
but uh,
there's a map of Antarctica that they,
it's completely unexplained.
Hold on a second.
Angry ancient map.
Okay.
And Artico
by the way,
a Birdie Stevens,
new TV show on HBO go comes out August six.
And if everyone just downloads it and watches it occurred,
give Brody,
but I think we're in it.
I think they right from Brody dark podcast.
Yeah.
So they came here and they used to also used a lot of footage from when I used
to use stream with him at right before his meltdown.
So I think their youth,
they used a lot of that stuff.
Oh,
the craziest stuff.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
It's called Brody Stevens.
Enjoy it.
Pull up.
Um,
uh,
an ancient map of Antarctica.
Pull that shit up.
Pull off.
There's a Google image search.
It's amazing.
Antarctica.
See there's a lot of shit about the past that we probably don't know.
I mean,
how much do we really know about anything more than 10,000 years old?
Not a lot.
It's a lot of fucking sketchy information out there when it comes to the,
the,
the history of humanity.
But this a map,
I believe it's from the 15 hundreds and um,
go do a Google image search.
Yeah.
That's uh,
yeah.
I believe it's from the 1500 centers have Indiana Jones.
Let's complete mystery because we didn't discover Antarctica until,
I believe it was the 18 hundreds,
cause it was just completely frozen and covered at nice.
But these motherfuckers from the 15 hundreds had a correct map of the outline of
Antarctica.
They knew where it was.
They knew what it looked like.
Fucking nuts,
man.
We don't know how.
I think there's a lot of this shit.
They're,
they're,
they're too arrogant with their placing of,
of the time that history was invented in the time that civilization was
invented.
I think they got a little stuck on their timeline and now the shit is shifting
like really,
really radically like far back,
like a recent,
um,
uh,
discovery in Africa.
I think they pushed the,
the start of civilization back another 20,000 years.
It's pretty nuts,
man.
Stop and think about how fucking long ago that was,
there was nothing blink of an eye that,
to this,
that to Tom Rhodes on the Internet right now and performing the Ice House Comedy
Club here in lovely downtown Pasadena.
I SAS company.com for tickets.
Tom Rhodes.
Dot.
Net profit on roads.
Where are you based out of now?
These shoes?
I don't live anywhere.
I've had everything in storage for like six years and just travel constantly.
Wow.
That's weird.
That's a trouble with your wife.
Yeah,
she travels with me.
Oh,
that's bad ass.
She's,
she's in Holland right now.
Uh,
when we,
uh,
Jeez European.
So to get the green card,
you had to,
she couldn't leave the country for a year.
And then,
um,
I just did two months all over Europe and she was with me.
And so she's visiting her mommy working on her stuff.
And so you just go,
you don't,
you guys don't have a house anywhere,
you don't know.
And then one where,
uh,
you know,
like last year I spent a month in Asia,
there's great tours all over Asia right now.
Uh,
and then we spent a month in Australia,
four months in Europe.
Uh,
and then we'll take a little trip,
like we had a couple of weeks off when we were in Asia.
We went to Bali and just
give you a hard time.
Like,
can we just get an apartment,
kill me,
I want a place to put my shoes.
No,
that was always hit.
I was like,
you know,
going through these,
relationships that didn't work out.
I was always like,
God,
why can't I find a woman that likes to travel and sleep late and laugh a lot?
And,
uh,
I found her.
That's awesome.
So it's so great.
And she's a photographer,
so you know,
she,
uh,
she's just looking for art everywhere and she's awesome.
She's fun.
It really is all about finding human beings that you're compatible with.
You,
you know,
you,
you're better because of them.
They're better because of you.
You pump each other up.
So many people get in that negative fucking relationship loop.
And it's so common with comedians.
It's almost like a cliche.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
to hear a guy like you who's living this crazy life of travel,
but yet you're very happy,
you know,
it's,
it's nice to hear that when you find someone that's a,
yeah,
she's an amazing,
she's an amazing human being and she loves comedy and she loves hanging out with
Comedians and yet she still hangs out with you.
I got a tiger lady,
uh,
which,
you know,
it's awesome.
And so it's never like,
oh,
give me the evening.
It's always,
she like,
she loves hanging out with a comedian.
She,
she,
she loves the,
you know,
the,
the jokes and the creativity and she's a great Laffer.
It's amazing when you look back at your life and all the people that you could
have wound up with.
Isn't it?
Like,
I'm so glad I waited.
Yeah.
I'm so glad I waited and they're probably glad that you waited
too because he became a different person along the way.
You know,
you evolved along the way.
I mean,
if you met this chick now when you were 20,
you might've fucked it up.
I always look about,
but if you look back at like some of the relationship that you were in and some
of the shit that you're tolerated,
like,
oh,
what,
you just,
you would roll the dice.
You meet someone,
they're pretty cute.
You have a conversation,
you get a phone number,
you make a day,
you try to be cool with each other.
You don't even know how crazy they are until you know you're three months in and
you've been fucking run out of condoms
two months.
You know,
you don't even really know how crazy she is.
Right.
It's always,
you are always the crazy girls that are the,
you know,
the,
the uh,
you know,
psych clones in the sack.
Man.
I remember I was with this girl and she was nothing but a headache and just
wanting to argue about such minuscule shit all the time.
But she was a butthole liquor.
Oh Jesus.
And you will stay in a bad relationship two years longer than you should for a
girl who like tongue grayness.
She like picky about when to do it or was she like right after the ball?
No,
no,
no shower.
No,
no.
It was always,
it was a,
it was a timely surprised that she knew how to deal out.
It's a timely surprise.
Did you,
did you like shave your ass for a no.
If you knew she was,
you let it go.
Handling.
Wow.
How clean does it ever really goes?
I mean how much are you washing down there that you're allowing that girl look
your ass like that.
Why?
I was,
I was scrubbing pretty ruthlessly when I wouldn't be trusting my hair's down
there.
That's like,
that's like saying here,
wash your face with this washcloth that I've been shitting into in the past 30
years,
but I cleaned it really good.
Those hairs,
who knows how long those hairs or cling to your asshole.
That's terrible,
man.
That's a really romantic story and turned it into a little dingleberry festival
is funny how you look back on,
especially when I get really high,
that's when it really jolts me.
When I really start thinking about like girls that I dated like 20 years ago or
whatever,
you really start thinking like how,
how insane,
like those look really young,
early relationships where how ridiculous they were.
You know what?
What a strange thing it is.
Especially back then when you would or you would run into people,
you would try to figure them out,
is this going to work?
Can we can do it up?
Nope.
Gotta go rotten and then get away from it.
Then there was no fucking text messaging.
There was no email.
It was like that was it.
You take care.
Gone.
I know in Skype is the greatest invention in the world now.
It's like,
you know,
traveling and you remember how like expensive it used to be,
like make a phone call and a hotel from the hotel room to call your mom or your
girlfriend.
Right.
Especially in natural,
you know,
God,
it's,
you can talk for hours,
for free on Skype and look at each other.
Well,
it's weird,
right?
Incredible.
What a weird world.
We live in a wonderful world.
It's just the beginning,
just the beginning.
But in these Google glasses go live,
have you seen these fucking things,
people walking around with glasses,
that information in front of him,
like the Terminator?
Yeah.
You know,
I've had everything in storage for six years here in Los Angeles because that
was the last place that I lived.
Uh,
and what do you have in store?
Well,
that's what I was gonna say is I can't wait to get everything out of storage to
see what electronics I've been hanging onto,
to do,
you know,
like the technological leap that we've made in the last six years.
Like,
I think I've got like a,
a,
a Sony Walkman.
I think I've,
I think I've got like an answering machine who hoo,
fuck it has an answering machine anymore.
I love going through my old answering machine tapes.
I don't know if you've saved a bunch.
Uh,
cause I had
one though where you could do the,
the cassette thing and uh,
I would,
I would take it out and change it all.
I think I've got like 10 or 20 go through.
I just recently went through some on mine.
It was all amazing.
Listen,
a couple of people were dead in it,
you know,
my grandmother and like and stuff.
I'm like,
wow,
this is crazy.
I didn't even know I had this.
Oh yeah.
I used to have a buddy of mine had died of a voicemail message from him and I
listened to over and over and over again.
It's a weird thing that you could record someone's voice when they're dead long
gone.
They can have an impact on you like music.
So listen.
Yeah.
Like my,
my father died and I wish I would is,
I,
you know,
I wish I had saved all of his voice messages and,
uh,
my sister died last year,
breast cancer and I did a podcast interview with her,
uh,
like six months before she died.
And I'm so glad that I recorded it.
Um,
because it's great to hear her laugh and the way that she,
the way she expressed herself and her humor and her vibrancy and,
um,
it's like,
I think we should do that with,
do that with everybody you love.
You got the technology and um,
it's,
I'm so glad that I have her voice recorded on this conversation.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing to think that someone could just not be there anymore.
You know,
someone that you love so much and you maybe feel like you didn't get a chance to
say that to them.
Yeah.
You got to say that to people all the time.
People just appreciated people more.
There's these things that people used to take called ordeal poisons and uh,
they,
they would take him in indigenous areas that didn't really have access to
psychedelics and their ritual,
they're coming of age ritual would involve these ordeal poisons.
And you know,
they're,
they're shamonic rituals.
We have all this stuff.
And what it does is,
is like some chemical that almost fucking kills you,
almost kills you,
just fucks you sideways for a couple of days.
And then when it's over,
you feel so grateful that you're healthy again,
that you've like,
you changed your life.
Well,
there's nothing like almost dying to make you appreciate living.
I almost drowned in Thailand once scuba diving and really and yeah,
and then for like it was bad equipment.
And two is this,
is this French,
a resort in this,
a tattooed criminal scumbag,
a diving instructor from Mo Pta Phillipe.
And there was a reason why he was hanging out in the pee islands in Thailand.
You could just smell the cocaine criminal past on this guy.
And he was the diving instructor.
And then there was a,
a French girl,
Helene.
She worked at a Bordeaux International Airport for Air France at the ticket
counter,
and she was my diving partner and Oh my God,
this is going to be perfect.
I was single at the time.
This is going to be love Helene.
And uh,
Felipe also had a crush on this girl.
So every day,
oh,
so the,
there's the,
the,
anyone who's ever been diving has to study a book for a week before they get in
the water.
I didn't,
the morning of my first dive,
I sat with a very hung over and he went over the hand signals with me.
Uh,
this means I cannot burry the,
this means I have a love of Ar,
a love of air.
Okay,
I'm under water.
Oxygen is precious.
No,
this means you are low of air.
Let's get it right.
Frenchie and so anyway,
every morning or every day has underwater flirting was outrageous.
He pushed me aside and be showing this girl around and I'm in the background.
And who's a girl you were with?
No,
no,
no.
But she was my diving buddy.
Oh,
okay.
It just worked out that he knew and he just fucking,
you know,
pushed me aside.
And,
uh,
you know,
cause you're grouped up and,
yeah.
And then,
so he's saying shit to me throughout the week.
Uh,
he just keeps fucking with me.
please.
Uh,
we'd all like talked about what we did.
It was a French and English couple,
mark and Mara,
and they were,
they had lived in Paris for five years,
so they spoke fluent French.
And so we all talked and he was like a,
a stock trader.
And I told him that I was working for this Dutch travel TV show.
And so he keeps calling me Mister Television,
please,
Mr Television.
Uh,
you,
your buoyancy please.
Like anybody who's been diving,
you know,
you just touched those buttons.
Professional divers never used their hands and they're,
they got perfect parallel.
And,
uh,
everything Mr Television,
you,
he's just yelling at me and,
and,
and the morning that I almost died,
he was really addicted me.
And I said,
look,
Phillipe,
I gotta tell Ya,
you're making me feel uncomfortable.
You know,
I gotta trust you down there.
And he goes,
Ms. Dot.
American.
Have I hurt your feelings?
Maybe Zay Al-qaida has asked me to leave your body and say ocean today and then
this English guy mark,
it's all EEG.
You are out of old us.
Uh,
it was as him or do you?
To the French guy and it was just,
you know,
almost,
it was just really on the other guy was a,
he was,
he was defending me,
but he was a resident as well.
I mean he was,
he was in the diving class.
There's four people in the class,
this English couple and me in this French chick,
Helene.
And so we're paired up into,
you went in the water anyway,
even after all,
well,
yeah.
And then it was like this a,
I'm getting water in my,
in my breathing.
You think you fucked with you?
I don't know.
I might've though.
Right?
I mean it just seems think so.
They said there was something wrong with the tank and in retrospect it was
Russian roulette and I got the bad tank.
And so,
uh,
my spare tube is getting water.
I'm hitting the button and I'm still getting water.
In your lungs don't want water.
And um,
it was like,
it wasn't that deep.
It was only like 40 feet,
whatever.
But it was deep enough to be dangerous.
And I knew you couldn't shoot up to the top and he's way ahead of me and I swim
to this French fuck as quick as I could and who'd have thought I ever would have
got to use the,
I cannot breathe signal.
And he just seemed to really take his time getting me that extra respirator.
And by the time it hit my mouth,
I had held my breath for so long.
I did.
His death bark came out of me.
It was the sound of someone dying.
And it came
out of me and I really thought this is the last moment of my life seeing all
these bubbles and this French guy's face.
And he got me to the top obviously.
And then he asked to take,
uh,
when we got back,
he invited me to go into the little village and have a beer.
And uh,
I told him,
you know,
I,
I learned true buoyancy today cause it's all about true poignancy.
And diving,
you know,
uh,
I said this morning when you said that shit about al Qaeda wanted you dead,
I hated your guts,
but then you saved my life and no all's forgiven.
Wow.
I learned the true meaning of true buoyancy.
Oh.
So then like,
wait,
how did he respond to that?
And he was okay with it,
you know,
he was okay with it.
You know,
he wasn't like a,
a powerful moment between you guys.
I mean,
you saved your fucking life.
Yeah.
I mean he,
I think he was glad that I didn't die because it would've cost him his job and
he,
you know,
it was okay.
It was a nice moment.
Do you think he was a hardened dude?
You didn't feel like he's a hard guy?
He had been in jail.
He had been in prison in France.
There was a reason.
Really.
Yeah.
He had like these homemade gel,
jailhouse tattoos and uh,
you know,
he was just a,
tough guy and that doesn't just got back to the bruise a Douche bag.
He was a Douche bag.
I got back to the resort and by the water there was this little Tiki hut bar and
Helene was there and she spoke forwards of English.
I spoke forwards of French and I'm making small talk with her and I go,
um,
so what's the first thing you're gonna do when you get back to Bordeaux?
She goes,
make love to my boyfriend.
He was like,
Oh shit.
I didn't even have a chance with this girl.
I risked my life.
Jesus Christ is the second thing you're going to do.
There is no second thing.
He,
you,
I almost died for you.
Whore.
Wow.
We trying to impress her and away you went deep.
Yeah.
You don't,
when you're on vacation in your mind plays tricks on you.
You're like,
oh yeah,
so you were on vacation with this girl,
but there was no,
no,
no.
I was doing this Hong Kong Thailand tour and I was working for the Dutch travel
show and they told me if I got certified diving while I was in Thailand,
the next assignment they would send me to the Caribbean to for,
so uh,
I had two weeks off,
stayed on cope pp,
this wonderful little island way out in the Bay of Bang Gal,
you fly like an hour and a half from Bangkok to poop cat.
And then you take a boat in the for like four hours out into the Bay of Bengal
before you get to the PPI islands.
Wow.
And it's where like a,
around that area is where Leonardo Dicaprio did the beach.
Great movie.
I liked that man was a really,
what was it about a guy almost drowning in Thailand now?
They,
it was,
they were there in paradise.
They don't wanna leave.
Yeah.
They swam to this island.
They found like these people that lived on this island and it was like a secret
and then they,
you
know,
it's just a,
it's a cool movie.
I tend to always like Leonardo movies even though his gaze that sounds,
but like basketball diaries and ception like all these,
maybe the gas tank,
boom,
boom Gilbert.
Great.
What a great movie.
Yeah.
Did you see the uh,
j Edgar Hoover?
No,
I never saw that.
Interesting.
Not really that,
I mean it was,
it's a really fascinating study on a guy who just had an incredible amount of
power and kept it to the end,
just clung onto it.
And it's like,
it's an interesting to see the struggle and his weird problems,
you know,
accepting the fact that he was gay and really weird fucking guy,
man.
I'm the fact that that guy somehow or another rose to the position of like the
secret keeper in the world of politics.
Really fucking kind of creepy.
Yeah.
You know,
the system was so shitty that this creepy can,
could fucking,
he could be the one pulling everybody's strings.
Like,
what'd you do?
How'd this guy get there?
They never,
they never offered to me and they had secrets on everybody.
They never offered him,
you know,
and it became,
it must be madness at the end.
I must've been like,
this guy must have had shit stored all over the place.
But see,
everybody wins the case.
They killed him.
Casey was in a plane crash or some shit.
All these Manila envelopes gets sent out.
Yeah.
I mean that's probably the only way to stay alive.
If you got some secrets about people like that and some high order,
well,
pay me.
That's how,
that's how Putin rose to power because he was in the KGB for for years and
apparently that's what I heard about Putin.
Really?
He had shit on everybody.
He makes our fucking politicians look like such pussies.
He's always bare chested,
fly fishing with a fucking snowboard tucked into,
at least you see Obama without a shirt on.
You know,
a body surfing in Hawaii and stuff.
There's been shots of,
you know,
it's cool you live,
you look good guy.
Looks like he could still kick a little less.
I think Putin would fucking ever see Romney with his shirt off.
You don't think that Putin would fuck Obama and Romney Rodney up at the same,
oh my God.
Totally.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He would hip toss the first guy and after he hip dos Mitt Romney,
Obama would panic.
It wouldn't know again,
you know.
Yeah.
And he's a judo guy,
black belt.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
he learned some,
some,
some deadly shit in the KGB.
Know he's killed people with rocks.
You look at that guys face,
that guy has killed people with rocks.
He's probably killed people with forks.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he,
that's a motherfucker.
That's one of the craziest things about Russia is that that guy,
somehow another stays in power still in power.
They have this weird thing where he like,
he wasn't in office anymore,
but then he was like,
he had another position.
You became the prime minister.
It's kind of still running shit.
It's very strange.
Russia is a different world,
man.
How about Romney fucking up pissing off all of England?
What did he do?
You didn't see that,
but he went like right before the Olympics.
He said he had seen some disconcerting,
uh,
things that,
that he was worried whether or not the London Olympics would be a success and
pissed off.
David Cameron,
the Prime Minister of England,
he's in the Conservative Party,
which you think that would be his ally.
They're more like the Republicans are like the same kind of people.
Right.
And David Cameron pitch slapped him and he said,
uh,
you did.
London is one of the biggest,
largest bustling cities in the world.
He said,
it's easy to put on an Olympics in the middle of nowhere,
meaning Salt Lake City,
you Mitt Romney punk,
and just like bitch slapped him and in,
in,
in front on the world stage,
I guess that's a bitch slap that's about the Olympics.
Who gives a fuck?
Seems silly.
When I think is a fascinating,
really fascinating about this guy was the,
might not have paid taxes for 10 years,
right?
And that,
uh,
this guy,
I loved it.
The Democrats are playing that old Republican dirty game that was always the
Republicans did the dirty ads and shit.
And the Democrats that,
I love that ad where Romney singing America,
the beautiful off key and then they show he's got his money in The Bahamas,
in the Cayman Islands.
He cares so much about the United States that he keeps his money off foreign
shore.
It becomes a problem though when you really accept the fact that the guy's a
businessman.
I'm not saying that what he did wasn't unethical,
but if it was legal,
there are sort of obligated by their shareholders to do the things that profit
them the most as long as it's within the legal parameters and
right.
But the personal taxes,
there was a eye on,
on like a potis on serious that I heard as a Romney speech,
like six months there.
I don't know,
whenever his tax has just came out three months ago,
whatever that was.
And some guys stood up at his speech and said,
uh,
on your personal taxes,
it says you've got one point $6 million invested in foreign countries outside of
the United States.
Why isn't that money being invested in the United States if you care so much
about it?
And he goes,
oh,
well,
how was unaware of that?
I'll have to look into that.
You know,
if you're unaware of 1000001.6 million fucking dollars,
that shit's ridiculous.
Yeah.
You know,
Romney's desperate because his new campaign slogan is Mitt Romney.
He's not the black guy.
Oh,
how dare you work in material into show up.
Dare you sir.
How dare you?
I think it's ridiculous.
I think it's,
this is the biggest shell game ever.
We're,
we're still playing it.
We're still soccer's pretending there's a real election going on.
Same fucking companies are paying his campaign and this,
there's a lot of cross campaigning and they,
you know,
it's a bribery.
We,
we've passed laws.
The Supreme Court is completely failed us and they pass laws that allow these
corporations to donate as much money as they liked.
They act as an individual and they can make massive donations and that affects
law.
And that's
who was,
I think it was at wilderness.
Some comedian a few years ago said that politicians should be like race car
drivers.
They should wear the,
um,
their corporate sponsors ours.
Yeah.
That is hilarious.
I think that was durast might've been it sounds like him.
Yeah,
it's genius.
It is.
It's true.
It's nonsense.
I mean when you feel like doctor drew got paid,
you know,
over 100,000 for a,
I think it was more than that 200 and something thousand dollars to promote
certain certain antidepressants to promote their off shelf properties.
Like a fact that they make you horny or something and they're better for for
sex.
Like he hear that and you'll come on.
Really can't trust anybody.
You can't trust anybody.
Is everybody getting paid off?
Everybody getting paid off as I hock Alpha brain at the beginning of my
swear to God,
I wouldn't have it if I didn't.
I just got a competent comment on there.
Anybody who's not for sale,
I own hypocrisy.
Okay.
I'll try to keep it as real as possible.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's very difficult,
but that is real brain Israel.
No,
no one diet for you.
No exercise.
No one.
I told you I just started doing the yoga.
I do vitamin
C,
multivitamins and shit.
Fish oils,
the shit.
A lot of fish oil.
It's amazing.
Make u joints feel better.
I take fish oil and a multivitamin.
Do you a count down the days till the singularity when you can download your
cell phone,
your computer,
are you thinking about that for the future?
What's that?
The singularity.
You don't know whether,
um,
you ever hear live race Kurt's while any of that shit,
futurists that believe that artificial technology or artificial intelligence
rather it's going to be,
uh,
the,
the next stage of existence.
We're gonna be able to download ourself into machines.
Nothing.
That's actually,
I figured that to me to be right up your alley.
Somebody mentioned that to me the other day that this is,
we're living already in it.
This,
this virtual world that there is some uh,
economist came up with some,
some like secret computer code in the forties.
Then we're already living in this.
Uh,
and I was like,
simulation send me,
it's called
simulation theory.
It's been all been talking about with my friends.
Me and Duncan get on the phone almost every other day and talking about
simulation theory.
And so the thing is there's Duncan Trussell.
Yeah,
that's who told me this.
Oh,
there you go.
Perfect.
That's who is that?
That's who I was talking to.
It was Duncan who's also perfect.
I was like,
Shit,
I can't afford property and this,
this,
this world.
Either.
He and I discussed this all the time and it's uh,
it's what it is,
is particle physicists,
I believe it was or whoever the fuck it was.
He's the string string theory theory.
Uh,
guys,
they found some sort of very specific code and a in the nature of reality,
you know,
like there's the Fibonacci sequence and this that's like what faces are designed
certain ways and sunflowers are designed set more.
There's called the golden ratio,
I believe it's called.
Or is that pie?
Whatever it is.
The FIBONACCI sequence is a number sequence that exists in everything and exist
in pine cones,
sunflower seeds,
the way the petals of a flower Barat blossom,
the way the branches of a tree.
It's all to a,
a very specific mathematical code.
It's amazing.
It's amazing when you really stop and look at the fact that while this might
really be some crazy one in zero program,
you know,
but Dunkin is obsessed with it.
And as am I,
we talk about it every,
it sounds,
I mean people get pissed and we talk about it so much on the podcast because it
becomes like almost a repetitive topic but it's still fascinating still to me.
I can talk about a hundred days in a row and it's still fucking tweaks my head
because it's going to be real someday.
Someday.
If look,
if you believe that TVS didn't use to exist at one point in time and someone
invented it,
that that that mind blowing change is just one step and an infinite process of
constant technological reinvention,
innovation,
new shit constantly coming down in an ever escalating pace.
If one day we can envision or virtual reality,
we easily could be in an already,
why would you mean you're not going to know if that would suck.
If you,
if you wanted to live this fake life and you know you would have like,
like,
like tabs to quit x here,
you know like little floating tabs in your life where you could put,
you would never think about the life being real anymore.
You wouldn't even really like it or appreciate it.
You can't have the tabs.
You can't have a way out.
It's all in.
It's all in the simulation or not.
We're not.
You know,
it was just horse shit.
Maybe it's just hippie nonsense while you wait for the end.
She brought that kid that got shot in the back seat of a car.
The cops was handcuffed him and shot him in the head.
They said he shot himself.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I'm no though.
This is a new one.
The Anaheim,
they've got fucking military in a,
in the street arresting people,
shooting rubber bullets at people,
arresting people.
It's crazy.
They're wearing camouflage.
It's real bizarre.
It seems very strange when you see them.
It's a,
there's a whole different thing when you see them wearing like this Iraq desert
military camouflage.
Like why is,
why are you wearing desert camouflage in Anaheim?
And what the fuck is this place in the world?
That's why,
but it's almost like you're wearing your gang colors.
Like you're letting everybody know,
like this is the military,
you know,
this is a,
this is the,
this is our gang color.
We were like sand camouflage.
Well,
I,
yeah,
I think it's the future.
When I lived in Amsterdam,
I guess 2002 when the second Iraq war,
uh,
was,
was just about the start.
There was this massive,
uh,
anti war protests on museum plane,
this big piece of green grass by the museums,
museums square.
Um,
and all of these people,
like thousands of people were out there and from every direction at one point,
like it was,
some people started throwing bottles.
There was a few,
uh,
you know,
knucklehead hooligans who were throwing bottles and then all of the sudden from
every direction of this massive square about the size of a football field.
So you've got like six different streets coming into this rectangular big grass
area and from all six directions.
These,
I have never seen vehicles like this in my life.
These like,
uh,
like these millet to these grey military vehicles came busting in and
everybody's just running like ranks,
like tank look and things.
And they had water cannons on the top and these water cannons were like,
just
spray and pee on shooting him,
knocking people down like,
you know,
Alabama,
uh,
in the 60s,
Birmingham,
uh,
you know,
the fire hoses on people.
And I was like,
wow,
that's the future where they can just come in with these military vehicles and
just spray people.
They don't even have to kill them.
Just,
you know what the fuck though.
Really?
Yeah.
In Amsterdam.
That's crazy.
So Amazon's another ass fucking place.
They have the best kickboxers uh,
pretty much ever like it.
Even better than the Thai guys cause they're bigger people,
you know,
I mean if you want it to com,
compare it like the ties certainly of the more skilled practitioners,
but they're really lighter guys.
But they've had guys that have done really well in a gun over there from
Amsterdam,
even the lighter weights and compete and beaten the,
the ties.
But uh,
Amsterdam is super famous for a kickbox Holland in general,
super famous for kickboxing.
What's the one area developed like some of the best kick boxers of all time.
All the like big,
top name heavyweights.
A huge amount of them came from Holland.
Nice Remy bone chasky or Nesto who's,
it's also one of the world's largest banking entities.
Is it really?
That's the,
the ultimate trick that the Dutch do is they,
they want people to think it's all marijuana and tulips over there and
prostitutes.
But you know,
like the rolling stones and u two,
I think Coca Cola,
all these corporations are based there.
The Elvis Presley estate,
so they can get these uh,
um,
you know,
tax rates and stuff.
What kind of low tax rates are we talking about?
Like Mitt Romney,
low time to move on.
Maybe we met Tom to move to Amsterdam.
Damn.
Student gets cold there.
Dude gets cold there.
But on global warming kicks in,
I might be the spot.
Yeah,
right on the ocean start to rise.
Right.
Well,
and that's the thing,
it's underwater.
It's the low lands and that's why they have canal.
So if the,
if the oceans rise,
Holland will be non existent.
Have you seen the satellite images of Greenland,
Greenland for the first time.
I was no snow on it.
Wow.
Look at this.
So you pull that shit up Brian.
It's ridiculous.
They,
uh,
they,
they haven't had this happen since like the 18 hundreds,
I don't think Greenland.
And they're saying this is like one of the best,
uh,
signs that there really is some sort of global warming catastrophe that's about
to happen.
Well,
that already happened in a couple of hundred years ago.
When I just mean it's like,
oh,
it's just happened again.
Well,
the idea is it is going to happen again,
but we're going to have to figure out,
um,
how to,
uh,
how to move around it.
Like,
look,
did you see the pictures?
I'm looking at pulling out.
I got it right here.
So you go to Google image.
The first image shows you the extent of the surface mount.
It's pretty fucking crazy because Greenland is pretty much all covered in ice.
Did you see the first one?
If you go to Google a image,
just,
uh,
Google,
Greenland melted,
just Greenland melted and they're the first one.
The first one.
Now look at that.
That's what it used to look like on the left.
That's what it looks like now on the right,
there's no smile.
That's crazy.
I mean that's,
it's really hard to wrap your fucking head around man.
Hmm.
And uh,
I don't think that happens very often.
I think the idea is that that is pretty fucking rare.
I like what the people in Iceland like they named Greenland,
Greenland,
and Iceland.
Iceland.
So the Vikings would attack Greenland and Iceland.
Really?
Yeah.
Did they really?
Yeah,
because Iceland is actually,
the greener area is Iceland and Greenland is more ice and stuff.
I've never been there but isolated.
Apparently they named it that way,
you know,
to,
to trick the vikings so they wouldn't come up and rape their women.
That's hilarious.
But Iceland is a,
the place,
uh,
w how cold is Iceland yet?
I have no idea
what just happened in Iceland.
Something just happened there,
right?
They are the bankers.
They were holding him accountable.
Yes.
Here's that.
The trial there.
Yeah.
What do,
what do I get as much media coverage in the United States?
Because A,
we don't want to give our citizens the idea that we should try bankers.
That fucking collapsed our system.
They also had an the volcanoes active volcano two yeah.
What a,
yeah.
That was like a year or two ago and all this volcanic ash went all over Europe
and they did cancel flights and stuff.
Did you see that?
It was crazy driving dark cloud over it.
Yeah.
It's like they were driving and volcanics Chanel,
so they're holding the bankers accountable.
That's what's going on over that.
Few of them are on trial.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
It's like you have to almost have to be a small European country to figure out
how to do it completely correctly.
It's like when you become as big as the United States is,
it's like small European countries are really like states and it's like Texas
could probably be fine if it was left on its own,
you know?
I mean,
that's essentially how Europe is.
There's European countries that are smaller than Texas and I'll stay.
They're the only ones that could really get it together,
like fucking controls.
I think there's just a lot of people that don't give a shit in this country.
And that was what I found refreshing about the occupy movement.
It was like,
wow,
it's good to see that.
You know,
some people in this country are passionate enough to get out and protest.
Well the youth,
the people that don't have a lot invested already in the system.
The real problem is once people can invest in the system and they have a
mortgage and they have,
children are paying credit cards,
student loans,
boom,
you're sucked in with your lease,
your car payment,
you're sucked in and you gotta,
you gotta come continue to at least feed,
you know,
your portion of the system.
So that's all your motivation and energy has gone eight hours a day.
You're gone eight hours a day,
at least five days a week,
six if you have any ambition and all your piece of shit and that's you,
that's your life.
And what are you going to do for the route?
You've got a couple of hours left in the day where you going to eat and catch
your breath and jerk off.
And really probably barely get to the gym,
you know,
I mean,
there's no revolution time.
So when you get these kids in there,
you know,
18 years old and they got no future and they're looking at the future and
they're like,
you know what,
I,
I saw this one kid that actually said that he was like,
I'm joining a revolution.
He goes,
I realized that I can't,
I can't enter into a system that I have no faith in,
so write at a college.
I'm just joining a revolution and I'm going to be a part of this
movement.
Hopefully it's not the Pepsi Revolution.
Oh,
I don't think that's what he was talking to.
Like,
you know,
you look at you,
they'll get,
you know,
people in the sixties and seventies they stopped Vietnam and it,
there was
not really,
it took a long ass fucking time and they had no other way to justify it anymore
and they stopped something that they created under false pretenses.
They created a war or the fake the fucking incident to drag us into it.
Yeah,
that's right.
But that goes back to the Spanish American war.
There was an incident in the Havana harbor in Cuba.
Spain had a Cuba and the Philippines and we said that some ship had been
attacked of hours.
Uh,
I think it was the Bismarck.
What year was this?
I don't know.
We've always done it right.
And then so yeah,
and then so we went to war with Spain and we got Cuba and the Philippines.
Well the
Looney tooney people believe that this kid in Colorado is a government plan.
I heard that.
Well,
did you see the photos of like looking at his nose from the original photo they
posted that kid's nose is like really fan and then his like recent pictures,
he's got like a spread out nose that looks completely different and they're
saying like his ears don't match the old photo and like all this weird stupid
stuff.
It's ridiculous.
I'd looked at the photos,
I'm like,
this is just the first,
they're not,
these aren't crystal clear photos like sometimes in photos,
things like VOD and he's smiling and one your nose kind of stretches my nose
flares.
The idea is that he was somehow or another brainwashed and,
and sat in there
by the government so that they could take away our guns.
This was the,
this is the narrative is that,
you know,
from the really extreme Alex Jones type individuals who believed that the
government is constantly plotting to take away your guns and slowly,
and you know,
he's,
he's right more than he's wrong.
Unfortunately.
Alex Jones,
thank God there is an Alex Jones.
I love the fact that there's this guy who is stirring up a things and he,
he's,
he's a,
he's lifting up stones and saying,
let's look under there.
You know,
he's fine and like ghost worms and shit.
Yeah.
I mean some of them,
some of it's Wacky,
but I,
I appreciate it.
Alex Jones.
I,
I like what he's doing.
I do too.
You know,
and then we,
you know,
he's a great guy.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
Great Guy.
Love
hanging out with him.
He's a great guy.
He actually just sent me a text today.
I'm not name dropping and nothing,
but I'm like that with Alex Jones.
I look at any texts that comes from him.
I'm like,
hello government
for sure you're reading this one.
I know you're not going to get anything to interest together be,
but Alex Jones might send you some interesting stuff.
I fucking guy,
man,
he'll uncover everything constantly,
all day,
every day and never take days off.
But he,
he believes,
how does he come up with all this information?
It's incredible.
I own the Internet and he's got a whole crew of people working for him in
Austin.
He's got a,
like a whole big office staff full of young killers,
you know,
young people that are like hungry and want to be down with the cause and they're
all working with them.
He's on an empire now or Alex Jones has a chai can tick like sort of underground
media empire,
but he's uh,
couldn't be doing any better than he's doing.
I mean it's like more the more and more his,
uh,
shit comes out and turns out to be true.
The more people just are at least paying attention to them.
You might not believe with everything he has to say cause sometimes he does go
deep,
but at least they're paying attention to him because he's,
you know,
did you see the shit that he predicted about it was a video called nine one one
road to tyranny.
And he had a,
he showed how governments have created chaos in,
in sort of in peaceful situation,
in order to allow the police and Rikers to come in and clear out peaceful
demonstrations.
And I had never thought that that was real.
I never,
I felt like that's crazy.
But he showed it and it showed evidence of photographs of these people wearing
military grade boots.
These cops that were,
uh,
dressed up like a hooligans,
they would smash windows and they were like sending their employees of the
federal government sent in there to cause havoc and rec per private property so
that they could bring in cops and closed down the peaceful protests or the World
Trade Organization.
And it's nuts.
You watch it and you go,
well,
you can't deny this.
This is something you can't deny.
Like this is what these,
these are the facts.
Those guys did do that.
The cops didn't negotiate with them.
They were released.
No charges were filed.
They really did break up the protest.
They really did stop people from wearing pins that's,
that had protests on them.
They had a WTO with a red line on it and they establish a line where you could
not come through with that pin on.
They established a no protesting line.
Even in what you are wearing.
That's,
that's some communist fucking North Korea type Shit,
man.
You can't even have a WTO pin with a red line through it.
I have to like say,
even though I'm saying nothing,
I have to subscribe to your ideology or I can't get through.
I can't even protest in the form of a pin.
That's that.
That anybody would allow that.
Like that is the most dangerous mind,
the most dangerous mindset that our government could ever have.
That you can't even just have a red line through this idea of a WTO.
I can't get to work.
I can't go into my room.
Really.
Alex Jones,
he uncovered all that shit.
So for people that don't believe in,
I'm like,
there's a lot of stuff that guy gets.
That's right.
Undisputable the fucking,
the Oklahoma City Shit.
That's some of the scariest stuff ever,
man.
When he,
uh,
goes deep into the,
the mysteries behind Oklahoma City,
that,
uh,
the,
the damage that was done by that fertilizer bomb,
the video of the FBI pulling on,
uh,
an blown bombs out of the building.
You know,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
Conspiracies are nuts,
man.
It's so,
it's such a mind fuck to think there's so many people out there conspiring to do
creepy shit.
And you've got to like break each one down,
you know,
decades later still trying to figure out who killed Kennedy.
Huh?
Fuck did they do it?
What happened?
Well,
Oklahoma City,
no fertilizer bombs and do that kind of damage.
Ah,
you know,
mind fuck you into a state of paralysis where you can't get anything done.
We're all going to do is thinking about who would thermite in nine 11,
you know,
fucking thermite and cut through these beams.
And I had to tell her seven fall man,
how did towers have it fall?
You could lose your whole life and then she,
right,
but then again,
you know someone's got to bring it up.
Right.
Keep these bastards on their toes as well.
Does it work?
Tom Ross?
I don't know.
Do you think is,
is there anything that is going to keep tyranny on its toes other than exposing
other than information?
I think as we lose all of our privacy,
that's what's up
eventually.
That's the thing.
I think it's naturally going to happen because it's just so,
yeah,
hard did keep things suppressed anymore.
Yeah.
It's hard to fuck people over when everybody's going to know everything that
everybody's doing all the time.
That's what the reality is.
The future is going to have no privacy.
Yeah.
Just Twitter alone fucking destroyed that.
Joe Rogan's at the olive garden with an Asian girl.
You had to say it.
You mother Fucker Olive Garden,
you son of a bitch.
Seven seven,
seven,
seven.
Brian is on an Asian kid alleys and when you referenced a girl,
it's always an Asian girl any bit.
Yeah.
So they were there with an Asian girl,
try new Asian material.
I know that it's all,
everything is all Asian these days.
Kids whacking the kids where I have this new theory that I told you about the
other day and I talked about it more last night with a couple of other people
about how my friend,
she's Japanese and I've been trying to talk as if I'm talking Japanese,
like doing like my impersonate personation of a Japanese person.
So I'm going like,
Oh Yada,
Yada Yada.
And then every couple sentences she goes,
oh,
you just said a real word.
You said you know apple or you said Taco.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's weird.
I wonder if like I do Chinese if I'm like bawling,
Dong,
Dong Dong.
And they're like,
you know,
that's apple,
you know that you just said a real Chinese word.
And that's just our impersonation of that,
that you know,
almost are racist version of what we think they sound like.
But yet there's some truth to it.
And so then I asked my Asian friend,
I'm like,
what do people that don't speak English?
Like what's their version of an English person?
Is it just like,
you know,
like I said,
our retard sound or something?
Don't you remember that song?
Do you remember that song that the Italian guy and put out,
he was a famous Italian singer and he put out a song that was his version of
like us doing time.
Like I don't know how to speak Italian.
Oh,
so if I was like [inaudible],
if I was making up words,
that's what he did.
But he did it.
And what American sounds to him,
pull that up.
It's a,
I think it's how the American language sounds.
Here.
I'll go,
I'll Google it real quick.
I think as a,
Tom Rhodes got a little baby bladder,
look at that huge cocaine addiction.
How American English sounds.
Yeah.
Rebut,
um,
tell sounds to foreigners how American English,
that's it.
How about what American English sounds to foreigners.
Okay.
And then go to videos.
Foreigners.
Here we go and go to videos and you'll see the top.
There's a
black and white one.
Click on that shit.
That's this guy.
It's really a Badass song.
Joey Dee has gotten mad.
Yeah,
I think we,
yeah,
maybe.
Yes.
Yeah.
Turn Up
Deacon [inaudible].
Well,
what happened?
Freezing cold in [inaudible] nine to [inaudible] Salem freezing cold in Madison.
I Jews off.
All right.
These are all fake words.
This is actually pretty bad ass
pretending is when the same shoes now and hoping to see the [inaudible].
I became the Co.
They miss a stay yet
hoping to see him.
Then rate maybe we used to call the boss ties pocket.
Bad Ass.
What does this Italian,
yeah,
it's no,
it's nuts.
Jibberish it's him trying to do television.
It's what his version would.
American sound like crazy,
but this all the time.
Susan Global Bank,
you have a customer that's called your brain to girls.
These bits.
That's crazy as fuck.
Yeah.
That's not a smart move,
man.
Just put a bunch of hot bitches dancing.
Right.
Great.
Listen to this.
This is the cool part.
They actually had like lyrics.
What does this dude's name?
Adriano's sell it ton.
Yeah,
he was,
apparently he was a famous guy,
Eddie cannabis.
It's pretty bad.
And that's exactly what I was talking about.
Like I didn't really know if that even existed cause you,
you know,
you always hear the like on TV and stuff,
you always hear like the,
the version of a Chinese person or you know,
or an African says a bunch of clicking noises and stuff.
Yeah.
But like you don't,
you don't know what English sounds like.
And it makes me wonder,
like,
you could tell that he had a couple of words in there that were like,
all right.
And stuff like that.
Yeah.
But uh,
but it's really weird trying to play that game and trying to find Japanese like
words.
Like I've almost made it a game where I'm just like,
all right here.
All right,
am I do this,
uh,
call y'all know [inaudible] you,
you know,
and then she'll be like,
oh,
you just said good morning and shoelaces.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's so weird.
It makes you almost wonder if it's somewhere built in your brain that you
actually know it.
Yeah.
I know you're getting lucky.
And up fake words
was only a certain amount of Chinese sounds you can make with your mom.
That's funny.
Well,
the language is very bizarre that like the Germans have such an [inaudible],
you know,
it's like what,
what,
what causes these,
these different like harsh sounds.
Right.
And it like Francis,
you know,
borders it and it's,
they speak a different language completely.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
It's bizarre.
When she speaks Japanese to you,
was it kind of tripping it?
Yeah,
it's super weird.
It's,
I think it's crazy.
I think,
uh,
um,
you Rishi.
Yeah.
Rishi.
Are you happy?
Yeah.
If you were going to learn a language,
that's a rough one.
We'll do the,
just the getting into the character thing again,
anything Spanish or semi European probably be fairly easiest for us to wrap our
heads around.
But,
and then all of these different countries I've gone to,
I've asked people,
how do you say,
are you happy?
Like in Dutch it's Ben,
you Holger.
In Japanese it's your Rishi.
I think that's the one question I want to ask people when I'm in a different
country.
It's a good question.
Are you asking to learn Dutch when you lived in Holland?
I Kline Beecham Manir a hell Moines avant.
Huh?
I don't know.
I mean,
she's asking you a question.
Don't gotta get fucking no,
not fluently.
I just know basic like cordial things.
But you were living there,
right?
Did you feel the need?
Like,
you know,
uh,
they are really strict on,
brown skin,
foreigners learning the language.
Uh,
if you're white,
I guess they are not as strict brown skin foreigners.
They don't want you to like,
yeah,
like a lot of Moroccan people live there and,
um,
they are really,
uh,
tough on them and you got to learn the language.
But,
um,
yeah,
no,
I,
I got by,
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So they're,
they,
they hold them more accountable.
They hold,
they hold a dark skinned immigrants more accountable than
I'm Moroccans,
like known to be like wild.
Is that the deal?
Well,
it's interesting,
their breakdown,
they're kind of like,
um,
uh,
our American,
a black youth where they get blamed for everything.
The teenage boys get blamed for all the crime and um,
uh,
it's,
you know,
uh,
did their,
you know,
typical gang bangers,
but it's,
it's like immediate perception.
They get a,
they're the,
they're the um,
shit on people there.
Do you know who
Badr Hari is?
You ever heard of him?
No.
Famous Holland dies.
I tick box or like one of the best kickbox is in the world,
keeps getting is a Moroccan guy,
keeps getting arrested for beating people up outside.
He's like heavyweight kickboxing champion and fucks people up on the street.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh,
him fucking people I've met no on this.
Nice that he's such a great fighter.
And then he's from Holland and these were on,
but he Rockins are known to be wild folks.
No,
I uh,
I mean,
you know,
they're,
they,
they kind of blamed for crime and things there,
but uh,
yeah,
there's,
there's some Moroccans that are bad asses.
Did you feel overall safer?
They're here.
Uh,
I have like a existence there.
You know,
I lived there for WWE for a love story first and then I was on television for a
few years and,
and I really got to,
um,
experience Dutch culture.
Like even a lot of Dutch people don't like I had this magic passport on the
country.
Uh,
my favorite thing about the talk show was every episode I would make a five
minute film on Dutch culture where I would get to experience something of Dutch
culture.
Like I spent a day with a Dutch farmer once a,
I walked into an electric fence.
He said,
look out for the electric fence in Dutch.
I don't speak Dutch.
Uh,
I got to go to the,
I got to go to the feel like,
oh,
it was a,
it was an eye opener.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was jolting.
Uh,
I got to cover the prime minister debates.
I was down on the floor talking to the prime minister and they did an English.
Uh,
well,
I mean there are debates were in Dutch.
I mean,
I was there,
I was there with a press pass after the debates.
I got to ask questions,
but I was given a,
uh,
you know,
all these different tours of the red light district by a former prostitute that
did a lot of social work for,
um,
you know,
prostitutes,
so they get their health care and pay their taxes and stuff.
Uh,
so I had this really magical experience here.
I,
I did actually date a Moroccan woman there for a while and it was interesting
because she was a really developed a European girl,
but to her strict Muslim family,
she was a different person.
Like she put on an act,
she could go out with me and you know,
have drinks and gonna Freak on dude,
you know,
non non Muslim activities,
Shit,
right in front of her family.
And so she could never tell their family about me.
Um,
partly because,
uh,
honor killings,
honor killings.
Yeah.
And I told her,
I told her once,
I said,
you know,
uh,
you know why,
you know,
you can't,
you tell your family about me.
And she said,
well,
uh,
I'm protecting you.
She goes,
I got some crazy cousins.
I don't know what they're [inaudible]
capable of.
Oh,
that's some dangerous pussy.
Tom Rhodes.
Could you feel that sense of danger while you were in that?
Did you feel that?
No,
she was,
yeah.
Well you're making,
I think it was a bit,
but that was a very typical,
very typical,
a Dutch story that did this,
you know,
Moroccan girl is,
she's raised in Europe.
She's very liberal,
open minded person,
but to her strict religious family,
she was a different person.
Those were the last holdouts.
Those,
those folks that want people to stick with their religion or stick with the
race,
those are the last holdouts of a dying generation of people that didn't want us
emulate.
I think once,
once we,
uh,
achieve the next level of assimilation with technology,
you know,
whatever it is,
whatever,
whatever's come that's going to make Twitter look like,
you know,
look like fucking sketches written on a,
on a wall somewhere as opposed to HD definition television and now whatever the
next thing is going to be,
it's going to bring him out.
My wife was your most worn,
but she's a,
she's,
she's Indian.
So do you think that language is eventually move on to one language?
I mean,
is that it?
Well,
I think we hit the lottery as far as language goes,
especially if you're a comedian.
There's all these great gigs all over the world.
And as an English is the language of business the way 300 years ago,
the worldwide language of business was French.
If you had a,
you know,
a global business,
you had to do your stuff in French,
now it's English.
Could you imagine though,
if the world spoken one,
I mean that's the whole idea about the tower of Babel,
right?
Who said that would,
it was designed that way to confuse us,
to keep us from progressing.
They gave us all a bunch of different languages.
We all got baffled and we went off in separate ways and we couldn't communicate
with each other.
So
as I tell you,
what's weird is a,
a friend of mine,
um,
I,
I know a few deaf people and I was asking them,
uh,
is,
is sign language universal and no sign language is different in Australia than
it is in,
in America.
What did you think that sign language for deaf people would be universal.
Do you think the one benefit of being deaf would be?
You could talk to a deaf person in China or that it was all the same,
but they apparently there are different all over.
There's what?
A pen.
The deck
sign language.
Uh,
what are,
what are their books?
Lock?
Yeah.
Did they ever have a books?
Never books.
It's just another sign.
Sorry,
just hands together.
Just the images.
Yeah.
I wonder if that's a good,
okay.
It's the,
the whole idea that human beings communicate so very differently all over the
world.
This is very strange.
I wondered when a Google translate came out,
if that was really going to have a significant impact on how we understand each
other,
but it still is so garbled.
You ever like try to convert Portuguese to English?
I love that.
That on the,
on the computer that on my Mac there's that little language converter.
It's nice,
but it's still clunky.
You know,
it is a little clunky,
but I've got cousins in Argentina and my mother's from Belinda Saturdays.
Oh yeah.
And I've been down there like three times in a lot of them don't speak English
and I'm friends with them on Facebook and they'll send me messages that are in
English to little choppy,
broken English,
but cool.
I know they put it into the language converter and then I'll be able to write
him back,
you know,
a little message and,
and do the same when I was in Brazil,
copy paste that bad boy
dudes would talk to you that way.
They want to talk to you in Brazil.
They would have a cool translate.
So they would cite to cite something in Portuguese and then put it in and then
hold it up to genius.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
It was cool.
It's a,
it's,
that's,
that's the future.
It's like somewhere that is going to be like,
why isn't there a movie once where a guy would talk to you when a foreign
language and it would convert it right in front of you and your ear.
That's the next shit.
Right.
That is the next shit.
Have you seen,
uh,
these,
um,
note applications on,
on iPhones where you talk into it?
No,
I don't see something crazy.
Let's say the shit out because this is amazing.
It's,
it's almost unbelievable.
It's a,
it works so quickly that it doesn't seem like it's real.
You press the thing,
like you want to have a thing,
there's a little microphone right there and I just press that and I go,
Tom Rhodes is a bad motherfucker.
And immediately
cool.
Look at that.
That's,
it's incredible.
And it's,
it spells it all right.
It capitalizes your name.
Nice man.
It's incredible.
So if you ever have any ideas,
you're in your car and you don't have to like pull over and write anything down.
You just press a button and start talking.
It's great fucking sick.
It's like Michael Keaton and I'm night shift.
Yeah.
How,
why should eliminate garbage.
How much time do you spend writing?
How much time do you spend like working on your act and you know,
I'm always adding little things.
Um,
you know,
I,
I just did an hour special and I just came out with a new CD.
So now I got to,
you know,
come up with a whole new thing.
So next year I'm going to do a different approach.
I'm going to do less road stuff.
Uh,
I like totally overbooked this year and,
um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna work less next year,
uh,
on just do you know,
world road stuff that I liked the best.
San Francisco,
London,
um,
you know,
Atlanta,
Sidney.
But I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna stay in California as much as I can next year and just like a,
do you know,
a short sets and work on coming up with the whole new next thing.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm in that phase right now too.
I'm constantly working on new shit.
I mean,
we do a lot of shows here at the Ice House.
That's why I'm psyche.
You're performing it this weekend and the place is a shit and we'll love it.
Is that place packed?
If you want,
if you want to go there to go to the ice house comedy.com and come see Tom
Rhodes,
you're,
uh,
you're the real deal.
You're out there fucking making it happen.
Tom Rhodes,
anytime you ever want to come back on this podcast,
I love you,
man.
It's so great to see.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
if I'm going to be spending more time here,
I'd love to hang out more in your hip.
Fuck yeah.
Dude,
we would love to have you,
uh,
you know,
come and do these shows these Wednesday and Friday shows are perfect for fucking
around and trying out new material though.
Audiences are amazing.
Thank you everybody that came out last night cause it was fucking sick that we
had like a three hour show.
It was nuts.
I mean it started out it was Brody Stevens and for her,
first of all,
Tony Hinchcliffe is hilarious.
That kid is a really good host.
He's really smooth.
Yeah.
And uh,
Joey Diaz went up.
Dom,
I rera went up.
Doug Benson went up,
Iko went up in Edwards.
Ian Edwards went up.
I mean,
it was amazing.
Bad boy.
Burbank deadband bareback bed pan,
the Burbank Bedpan.
Yeah.
Um,
thank you everybody for all the,
uh,
all the positive tweets and all the messages and thank you.
All these people that came to the shows.
Uh,
he looked everywhere we go,
we meet people that love this podcast and believe us,
we have a,
we feel a massive feeling of obligation an unquestionably.
We will keep this thing going.
We,
we owe it to you guys.
Now.
We started this weird thing.
I don't know where it's going but uh,
but we're having a good time so we appreciate the fuck out all you.
Thank you to Alienware for hooking us up with these badass laptops.
Check out this bitch,
look at that thing.
That's 18 inches son.
He can't even get crazier than that.
And it does like nutty graphics.
It's got to to video cards,
Sli,
go to alien ware,
MMA
on Twitter followed them.
They support a lot of MMA fighters.
So we,
we try to support them.
And a thank you to on it.com.
What are you doing?
You're getting crazy.
You're getting crafty thinking on it.com.
O,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha,
brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
and uh,
coming next week,
next Tuesday,
the hemp force,
the hemp protein shake is a,
is launching and that stuff is to shit natural.
It's all natural sweeteners with Stevia.
It's got cocoa in it.
All the information will be available on [inaudible] dot com go check it out to
buy supplements.
Use a codename Brogan,
save yourself 10% the kettle bells and battle ropes.
You cannot use the code name on that because we're selling them literally as
cheap as you can.
It's the highest quality caliber bell you can buy.
They're made by Troy,
but essentially it's very expensive to send cannon balls through the fucking
mail.
So I'm go get some,
go get it,
get on it.
Use a code name Brogan and save yourself some money.
All right,
somebody saved me this fucking podcast.
I can't stop talking.
Checkup,
Roadie Stevenson,
joy,
August six that's on Hbo.
Go download all of them and we're going in there somewhere,
I think,
and underscore underscore Tom Rhodes on Twitter.
We got to do something about that that other time.
Roads.
It's going to be getting mad tweets today saying your stories,
man,
we're awesome.
Was that standup comic?
Beep beep,
and we won't give that guy up,
but we should give that guy up,
but we won't give that guy.
Don't do it,
ladies and gentlemen.
The future's sneer.
It's closing in on you.
Suck it up.
Move forward.
Keep speaking.
Yes.
Big Love Word Salad.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].